i know
oops i didn't bring my gavel in but
that's okay we're not rowdy in here this
morning
so
i want to open our work session
the uh
first bill that we're talking about is
an advocate for special education
this is a new office
and it says it's
administratively attached to admin
services
under the direction of advocate for
special education
so
do i have anyone here that would like to
discuss this with us
it's like i guess that means we can
italia is that
is that how it goes
certainly i have a question
um
it says
in the rep and the committee report says
that um
we already have
an office of a child advocate but it
doesn't have the authority to take any
action but then it says if this pat this
passes we're going to have an
advocate for special ed
but but that office will not have the
authority to intervene either so
am i reading this correctly or so what
what will this new advocate do
is that a good question
can we hear from representative luno
he's here this morning and i believe
he's on education
and this went through education
okay come on up get the democrat
no
it doesn't matter
listen wait wait a minute that's what i
was doing we
are
we are all friends
no matter
no matter where we stand on the uh
on the issues so
let me just pull the
um madame chair let me just get my notes
first oh sure sure no problem from our
hearing um so um uh for the record my
name is dave luno uh representing the um
people of hopkins concord i serve on the
house education uh committee and um
yes we heard um um senate bill 381
back on april 11th and
and
had
substantial testimony
as well as
oral as well as written testimony i
think probably of all of the um
what we heard the testimony from
director sanchez the office of a child
advocate was particularly compelling um
that office is uh responsibilities have
recently been expanded by the executive
branch to include education and its
director sanchez's plan
to um
uh to bring forward in the next budget
a a request for um uh for uh an
education advocate you know as part of
that
that office
and um
according to
her testimony and according to the
testimony that was offered by
her um
her predecessor uh in that position
the um
things
of doing it through the office of the
child advocate would be approximately
three hundred and seventeen thousand
dollars off the bill's fiscal note of
five hundred thousand dollars so um sort
of you know just sort of rounding that
um the office of child advocate can do
it for about two hundred thousand as
opposed to five hundred thousand which
is what's proposed in um in
senate bill 381 i think beyond that
though
um the um
the minority uh recommendation
for this bill was uh was interim study
and um
and
and the um
the committee the the minority report on
that really did cite i think significant
flaws
in uh in the the 381 policy uh which uh
which wouldn't provide any authority to
do anything um uh you know in terms of
intervening with the students um you
know iep
uh
you know it would have no um
you know appeal author no appellate
authority nothing like that so um
so you know so i think um
i think an interim study recommendation
is good i think an itl recommendation um
is good and um and i'm i'm i'm sorry
that uh that director sanchez isn't
isn't here i don't want to you know
speak for her i certainly can't
but
but i think i'm representing her um her
um very impactful
um
uh uh testimony from from at least um uh
two weeks ago i think i'm reflecting
that accurately
so
if i'm understanding what what you're
saying
is that um
it's
probably
probably better that we itl it
and let
miss miss sanchez
come
in with a request for a bill
for next year to place this under
the child advocate
yeah good move and i and her her
intention is to do that through the
budget process and um she already has
authority for this in this area and um
and would uh would seek budget authority
for um uh for that higher
okay not a significant savings
yeah
when i read it's
it's very uh convoluted and
i certainly
am not real thrilled about the child
advocate
going to das but
that's just another right
another issue that i happen to have yes
represent lynn thank you uh thank you
for taking my question i i i completely
agree with you that that what you
suggest makes more sense than what the
bills as the way its traffic suggests
but i have a more fundamental question
and that is this
it seems like we've we've started to go
down the road with the office of child
advocate and you know i guess at the
public utilities commission for a long
time we've had a consumer advocate of
setting up
within
agencies or sometimes without agencies
uh a section that uh you know ex
and i'm just wondering if that
in itself makes sense i mean isn't it
you know
i guess the analogy i would draw is
wouldn't it make more sense to have
within say the department of health and
human services and the department of
education
kind of an internal affairs section like
they do with the state police or police
department that if somebody
is screwing up in the agency then that's
what internal affairs does but it's
within the agency and usually they have
you know a reporting situation so that
you know if you're if if uh
if the sergeant in the police department
is the person that's under investigation
then the internal affairs doesn't report
to that sergeant even if they normally
would have to
so that wouldn't it make more sense to
do something like that
just as as a general matter of operating
government than to have these new
agencies that you know are supposed to
are supposed to like look at the other
agencies
no you're you're absolutely correct
judge and and um and we did hear
testimony uh to that uh to that very
effect the department of education does
actually have uh an internal affairs um
element that's responsible for special
education and special education appeals
when when a family does not feel that uh
that that their student that their child
has been
you know properly represented uh during
the iep process and
uh and i i believe in the in the prior
year
that um that there were approximately
i'm not seeing it jump out of my notes
but i
seem to remember the number being
between 30 and 35
appeals that were adjudicated through
the through the department of of
education i think that's sort of like a
an annual sort of
number so they do have that process i
think as far as the office of child
advocate as opposed to the office of the
special education advocate right the
office of the child advocate would
would
by by by now having jurisdiction that
has been expanded to include education
and staffing appropriately for that
would would give them a more complete
ability to uh to provide child advocacy
services across the state
both both in terms of
of
you know health and human services you
know components as well as department of
education components so i think that
really does complete uh or you know help
make more complete the office of child
advocate role well thank you for a
follow-up so so i know i i mean i i i
think i agree with you i mean maybe it's
maybe it's we you know we've we've
already established the office of child
advocates so maybe
you know it's kind of too late to go
back and and and undo that but
and and so for that purpose maybe it
does make sense to and just give them a
jurisdiction to include education i
guess i'm just sort of thinking that
down the road i hope we're not going to
be establishing any more such agencies
right right and that's an argument and
and the oca argument that i was just
making that's for a year from now it's
not it's not today's debate so thank you
thank you thank you judge
by the way it's representative lynn i
know he i just
mad i'm sure i just haven't
i
i certainly understand representative
and we all have to remind ourselves all
the time
i prefer bob
well we're a little bit more formal in
our meetings here but uh yes i agree
okay
anything else no i think i think yeah
sure
thank you i think i understand but i
just wanted to clear up um
that there you know there's already
internal workings for this that this is
focused on the child not the agency
nothing you know what's going on in the
agency itself can you give an example of
what's not being done now that this
person would be able to do
thank you for the uh the question
representative
i'm i'm i'm not really it's it's not
clear from the from the
the bill
what this person's authority would would
be it is it is clear from the bill that
they don't have the authority to
to make an appeal decision or anything
like that the way
the department of education
does and has
and does every year
in these cases
okay
so representative turcotte did you have
a motion
unless there are any further questions
or comments
i'll make a motion to interim study not
itl
if somebody else wants to make an itl or
well welcome to do that
may i just ask a question of
representative turca sure
i'm not at all a quote i'm just
wondering if you uh i mean what you're
what you're thinking is on i may agree
with you i'm just not
yeah um
well somebody just asked the last
question as to what this um
what the individual would have the
authority to do and it is it's pretty
well delineated under duties and
responsibilities actually what that
individual would do
i don't know enough about this to
speak
really
in detail to it
but
such as things have the authority to
inquire of investigate review all
documents from any school district
special ed blah blah blah the advocate
shall have access to all iap documents
401 plans
discretion to
tracking metrics i mean there is a lot
of things in there i i agree that i'm
not convinced this is something we need
but i'm also not quite to the point now
that i think i want to make an itl
motion on him
do i have a second
i'll second it
okay
is there any discussion
go ahead
um
i thought the preference was to itl so
that i knew could because a new bill
will be coming in with with the budget
process next year
yeah
i just
i just don't think
that
um interim study
puts us in a situation of trying to make
policy right
and
if
the education committee had
thought
interim study was the right thing to me
that's the right place for it
not not that i uh
not that i mind making education policy
but
yet
but i i think that if in fact the child
advocate has the authority to do this
already
that it simply makes sense
for
that to occur
and um i know that
that will not come to division two next
year
but um
because
child advocate
is not part of our
of our
menu
so
anyhow okay
go ahead yeah and
and honestly the the only reason why i'm
i've kind of changed my tune a little
bit as i was i was reading the uh the
blurb on it from
house calendar 15
and the majority of the committee was
ought to pass
and it did pass the house
um
i'm just not comfortable making the itl
motion if somebody else would if we vote
this down if somebody else wants to make
that they're welcome to do that
okay will you call the role on interim
study unless there's some other comment
no it would the only comment i was going
to make is this i i will i am going to
vote for interim study but i should also
say if if but
if the consensus is that
interim study is inappropriate and
somebody else makes motion to itl i will
vote for that also
oh you want it both
i want it both ways yeah he sounds he
sounds just like a lawyer
what can i say
okay
all right uh this is a
motion for interim study on senate bill
representative petrie no
representative lynn votes yes
representative turcotte yes
representative bucca no
representative no representative no
representative umber
no i'm sure the vote is
five it's a
two to five in the negative so it does
not pass motion rgo
second
are there any comments
on itl
represent murray i just uh really
appreciate what you said uh regarding us
not doing the policy part of it
and that it makes a lot more sense for
education to do their job or whoever is
going to do their job to put this
together and bring it back in a budget
year
but i don't what would we do to interim
study
as we're not the education committee
we could cut thank you yes
we could
we could cut the uh
the money to zero you know
that's
all right um so this is a uh oh just a
second was there anyone else
clerk called the roll all right uh this
roll call on senate bill 381 on the
motion of uh itl uh representative petry
yes representative lynn votes yes
representative turcotte no
representative bucco yes
representative heath
representative murray
representative umberg
yes
i'm sure the vote is six to one uh in
the affirmative all right thank you very
much
uh represent petrie you will put
together
a blurb
okay
oh that was relatively easy
this morning i hope the rest of them go
like this
okay
um the next one is 394.
we had a
long discussion about that on um
friday
um
nikki you have a emotion or emotion an
amendment
yeah
i do have one draft you could make a
motion as well it's okay
uh i do have an amendment here that was
uh to be drafted and represent keith's
name but i can tell you they drafted it
with a different sponsor it's your name
representative amber as long as
everyone's okay with that i do have this
available otherwise we can hang on for a
few minutes till a fix comes can i ask
one question though
um in it did they um
in the amendment
does it still retain the section
about adult services
yes i i can i can distribute this if
thank you
oh um
they put the they put my name on the
amendment instead of representative
peace
she wanted to make sure that the
amendment
kept something in there
you dealt service section
thank you
okay
madam chair could we ask caitlyn to walk
us through this please
is that okay
certainly i don't care which or both
is it for debt
yeah
is it verdette or fournette
for debt
thank you just like my neighbor
his name
good morning for the record i'm caitlin
davis
i'm for the record i'm rebecca for that
okay i'm sorry could i get you
you rebecca ferdet and i'm sorry could i
get your name again caitlyn davis thank
you
yes
representative lin is new to this
yeah go ahead caitlyn would you we had a
discussion on friday and would you just
does this amendment do what i think we
agreed upon doing on friday
i believe it does so the discussion just
for the committee's memory and some of
you were not here um was to
have costs associated with funding these
kids for fiscal year to 22 and 23 be
funded from the department of
education's budget
and on friday i pointed out to the
committee that there is excess
appropriation for fiscal year
22 right now at about 1.4 million
dollars
from a line in the state budget known as
state special education aid previously
known as catastrophic aid i mean that
money
there is one additional use for that
money for the rest of this fiscal year
and then any additional funds
will lapse
so anything that would otherwise have
lapsed would now be retained by the
department to fund the costs
for kids
for
these pupils for
fiscal year 22 and 23 only so it's a
one-time funding that the department of
education will pay for the costs
associated with these kids
and
that was because of the committee's
concern on fridays that school districts
have already set their budgets for
fiscal year 22 and 23 so they would not
have time to appropriate funding for any
additional costs associated with these
kids so that was the purpose of this
amendment
it would carry forward any money in the
end of fiscal year 22 and fiscal year 23
to assume to pay for these costs these
costs would be paid out um in 20
fiscal year 24.
um because that that is the timing why
so um special education payments by the
state
usually are one year in arrears due to
the nature of the program
thank you madam chair
will that present a hardship to school
districts well
let me ask first my first question is
to make the school districts whole
we would be paying the percentage
that the child who's turned 21
um
the difference between the cat aide
percentage and the the full amount
would be covered by the school district
um under this amendment it would be
covered by the department of education
but without this amendment it would be
covered by the school district i'm sorry
yes i'm at the department of bed all
right so it covers
the whole thing
i believe so yes all right
and
my second question is my concern about
the local budgets
in that
we're in 22 right now
next year is 23 and you just said it
won't be paid out until 24.
that is the way that all special
education funding works so um school
districts right now incur
for example for we're in school year 21
22 um if they have a high cost special
education child that costs say 200 000
um
this school district goes through the
entire year takes the kids ieps and all
the expenses associated with that ieps
and sends all that information to the
department of education by july 1st of
each year and then the
statutory requirement to pay that
payment is on january 1st of the
following year so that is
the way the program is currently funded
uh representative he just
um
many school districts have
set aside capital reserve funds
to cover
this sort of this sort of thing right
and um
also
um
uh
many school districts also when we
changed the law that allowed them to
you know keep the money that wasn't
expended
you know they can
the school boards can authorize
this expense okay so it's it's not it's
not like
um the school's
it's it's not necessarily a zero-sum
game you know you know what i'm saying
the the money is
is
out there
and uh
as long as we have said in here some you
know that
um
they can spend it if necessary i i don't
know if that's
i think this is sufficient the way it is
okay
i mean that's normal
yeah thank you yeah i apologize for not
being here friday i was at a weekend
where i've tested negative both times
but i'm still being cautious with my
mask um
at 22 what kicks in to continue to
support these students i'm what i'm
reading this is that there is a gap
between 21
and 22
um because this only goes up to 22. can
i just get a little briefer on so thank
you sure
so the previous um bill had
the previous law had the students
covered for special education up to 21.
this bill brings it up to 22. so what
had happened for students at 21 will now
happen at 22 they typically go into
a community agency or they're picked up
by community services to provide the
services that they need
yeah and um this was
this change as a result of a court case
there's a yes there's a court case in
rhode island that follows the federal
law which says inclusive of 21 and so
any state that hasn't does not have that
language is
potentially subject to that
represent petri
thank you ma'am chair uh thank you for
taking my question now what what
community services do
who who in community services takes care
of these kids because a matter of fact
we got some information from attorney
zellin
that he used to say that at 21 they fall
off a cliff
so what's supposed to happen at 21 prior
to that actually is at 16 they're
supposed to be providing transition
services for students in the school and
they should be working with area
agencies to plan for that um exit at 21
22 whatever the the team has determined
and so they would work with area
agencies to get those services set up
for when they do exit um that does not
always happen but that's what's supposed
to happen there are 10 i believe 10 area
agencies that's run through dhhs but
there are 10 area agencies that provide
those services to developmentally
disabled um individuals now paul what
can you give me an example of some of
these agencies
that normally take care of these kids um
so in the lakes region there's lakes
region community services um in concord
it is uh
i don't work with them so i
struggle with community
uh bridges maybe i think it's community
bridges yep oh okay um so those those
are some of the area agencies that i'm
familiar with and they cover the whole
state
there yeah although those 10 different
agencies cover the state yes thank you
yeah we we have northern carroll county
no northern human services
that that covers our area
and i'm sure
there's somebody in your area that is
also responsible for that
but
as you said
the key is the coordination yes between
the school and the area agency
and you know so
i think the um
i think
the amendment
takes care of
the problems that that we think we have
or that we know we have
yes um one other issue um and i i think
was attorney zelling brought it up or i
don't know if you brought it up about
our
our special education schools say up to
do we need to amend anything in the
statutes about
uh the special ed schools in the state
like um spalding youth center or pi um
pinehaven i guess is one so our programs
are approved based off of what is the
current law so if the law were to change
then we would update those program
approvals for those schools
thank you
and that's this will take care of that
okay
representative lynn yeah i wonder
i apologize i was not i was here for the
first
meeting when this topic was brought up
about the those court cases and that
kind of thing but then i wasn't here for
the meeting in which the more detail was
discussed so i guess the question that i
i want to make sure i'm understanding
is am i understanding that right now
the costs of special education
putting aside the
the court case and the change that this
would make right now the cost of special
education there's essentially a sort of
sharing the state pays some of that but
the loc the the school district also
pays some is that correct
so we have um special education aid
provides
funds to schools
if they meet um three times the cap and
the cap is set by the per pupil cost out
of caitlyn's office and then once they
reach three times that cap the the state
will start to pay for
um 80 of their funds 80 of their bills
and then once you reach 10 times the cap
the state pays a hundred percent so this
the districts are required to pay a
portion right now the three times comes
out to just under seventy thousand
dollars um so they're required to pay a
portion but then we do kick in for some
of those um higher higher needs kids
with higher costs okay um uh follow me
ask a follow-up certainly
so i i guess the thing that i'm i'm not
completely clearly understand is i mean
i don't get me wrong i completely agree
that we need to
you know that that we need to follow
what the court decision said and if we
should be providing special education
services up to 22 then we
then that's definitely what we should do
i guess the thing i have some
difficulty understanding though is
i understand that school districts have
already set their budget
um but i'm not quite sure why that means
that
the state should bear all the costs of
this in other words
it's not
you know why it's it's not sort of
the state's fault any more than it is
the school district's fault so why
should
you know why shouldn't we say look this
is just uh
municipalities you have to pay
your section your percentage of the
costs we understand that you may not
have foreseen this but you know you
there are times when
when a lot of things happen that you
haven't foreseen
there was a proposal to the committee on
friday that the department of education
would pay that the department of
education then suggested the mechanism
of the funding in its current budget
that could
potentially
um pay for these costs but the proposal
for the state to pay originally came
from this committee okay all right
and also um
this was based on a court case
you know those terrible people
right yeah i know i understand that i
don't understand why that makes a
difference yeah and and the money was
available so it's not like we're um
having to um
spend
money
yeah
yeah no i said okay if i may believe it
the intention is to cover those
unanticipated costs up to that cap so
that 70 thousand dollars and then that
so it's not covering anything but that
70 000 is something a district has not
planned for so it's to try to assist
with that as we change this law more
quickly than we probably would have in a
different circumstance and i think i
think
rebecca said on friday that there were
four students
that are
up to 22
and
there were
yeah and there were 186
that are in the 20 age group
but they would have been budgeted for
because they weren't 21
okay
at the time
so these 186
more than likely will
not
reach
the 20
you know they could but
they could age they could turn 21 during
the year right and depending on the
school district the school district
could have planned for them to leave at
21. so it's to cover the cost from 21 to
the end of the year
or until they turn 22. yeah i mean it's
not like we're talking thousands of
of children
yeah
do we have some
some estimate of what that cost will
likely be i mean do we
it would be that that special education
aid cost so right now it's about it's
just under seventy thousand four seven
twenty percent so if you're if there are
only four that are currently in it we're
talking four times seventy thousand okay
all right that makes a difference to me
okay
representative not a question for the
ladies uh mr zollin will you be
testifying
thank you
we allow everyone
representative to talk
okay
are there any other questions
for doe
all right
mr zelen i
got your email early this morning you
must have been up late last night or got
up early this morning
would you like to come up and
yeah i really
think that all of the
concerns that you had
i hope we're answered by our amendment
right there
okay
well i'm having a better day than some i
once dropped mike into the well there
which was pretty embarrassing
um
hi i'm jerry zellen i'm a lawyer drum in
woodson i represent uh school districts
particularly in matters involving
special education i'm wearing my
lobbyist bin but i'm not being paid by
anyone to be here today i also was not
paid for the but i spent my weekend
writing for you
um
i but i'm here because i think the
issues are important and um
i'm you have my letter and
as you if you read my letter you will
see
that a lot of the um momentum for this
bill is driven by myths
um and so i'm going to uh for the sake
of time uh
focus my oral remarks on the myths that
have just been articulated this morning
if i may
um first of all there is the myth that
federal law and a court case demand
that we raise the age of special ed to
age 22.
now the federal statute does not
and in my memorandum i indicate
that federal law
creates a default raising the age of
special ed to the student's 22nd
birthday
but then allows a state to um have a
lower cut off age
if that is consistent with the state's
regular education law so in other words
the purpose of the idea
at its heart is to open the schoolhouse
doors to children with disabilities by
allowing children
who um if they were not disabled could
attend school
to allow those children despite their
ability disability to be able to attend
school and so the heart of the dis the
special ed law is equality parity and
new hampshire very clearly
guarantees regular ed only until the
21st birthday or receipt of a high
school diploma whichever occurs first
and new hampshire special ed law since
it was first enacted in 1978
has limited the
eligibility for special ed until the
21st birthday and no one challenged that
until
a decision by the first circuit came out
in 2018
that by a two to one vote
interpreted federal law
as requiring the state of rhode island
to offer special ed to the 22nd birthday
now why did the court reach that
conclusion the court looked very
carefully at the idiosyncratic
attributes of rhode island system of
adult education
and concluded that
looking at that adult education system
in tandem with the idea
it seemed that the id that the rhode
island was offering regular education
up to beyond age 21
beyond the 21st birthday and therefore
um rhode island had to offer special
education beyond the 21st birthday now
that was a two to one decision
and um there's which illustrates how the
idea
was ambiguous and it's very important
that the first circuit
when reaching that two to one decision
did not apply what the us supreme court
said
is supposed to be applied when looking
at a federal
grant statute that's ambiguous
according to the u.s supreme court when
a federal grant statute's ambiguous the
quote rule of clear statement applies
that's supposed to protect federalism
and states rights and according to the
u.s supreme court when a federal grant
statute's ambiguous it must be
interpreted narrowly to avoid
unanticipated consequences
and the problem is that the first
circuit
never
cited that decision because the rhode
island board of education's lawyer never
cited it in his briefs i read his briefs
it was shocking but nevertheless it
since it was a two to one decision
that's not the end of the a that's not
the beginning of the analysis at the end
of the analysis because the the court by
reaching a two-to-one decision basically
conceded that the statute was ambiguous
and therefore
um that should have triggered the u.s
supreme court's rule of clear statement
which meant well we interpret the stat
the uh statute narrowly rather than
broadly and i lay that out with
citations in my um
in my letter
so um
a court
if the if the rhode island case
if the rhode island analysis continues
to apply if the first circuit got a case
from new hampshire
and refused to
correct its error in the kl case it
would still have to look at
the idiosyncrasies of new hampshire's
adult education law
and see if they are similar enough to
rhode islands or very different and if
you look at new hampshire's adult
education statute it caps eligibility at
age 21 at the 21st birthday
so i think that to say that the idea
demands special ed to age 22 is a house
of cards
and to say that um the first circus
decision demand special ed to age 22 is
a quite quite a leap of logic
i i agree as a policy matter it does
make sense to raise the age of
eligibility to sp um to 22
but um to say that it's compelled by
federal law is really uh
a a gross overstatement
the other concern i have is that um and
i hear i fear i'm looking a gift horse
in the mouth and i apologize but
the amendment does do school districts a
great favor by avoiding the budget
disruptions that will occur
if this bill becomes effective
immediately when school districts have
not planned for that expense
on the other hand
this
the amendment is just a short-term fix
and um once that that fiscal year ends
then school districts will be
fully funding these the costs of serving
this expanded population range and by
the way on the amendment the amendment
refers to
the school year pardon me the a
particular school year which really
doesn't help answer
what happens with the ensuing summer the
summer of 2023
um but
more importantly at
no matter how uh
wise a policy might be
the the um
the ends don't justify the means and we
have a provision in our new hampshire
constitution
that prohibits new unfunded state
mandates
and raising the age of eligibility from
21 to the 22nd birthday
would clearly be a new unfunded state
mandate now now the new hampshire
supreme court has chipped away at that
provision of our state constitution but
there's one provision that remains rock
solid and that was based on the first
decision by our new hampshire supreme
court interpreting that constitutional
amendment which is if you have a a
benefit program
mandated by state statute but funded by
to any degree
by school districts or cities or towns
then expanding the population of
beneficiaries entitled to those benefits
is a violation of part one article 28a
of our new hampshire constitution unless
the state fully funds it
so um i'm here to urge you yes
raise the age
of special ed to a cap of the 22nd
birthday
if
you will fulfill the constitutional duty
of fully funding
the um all the special ed costs for
students between the ages of their 21st
birthday and their 22nd birthday and to
those who say well if we don't enact
this bill
we're going to face the costs of
litigation someone's going to
file a lawsuit raising the kl case um i
say to you two things
number one
the
the recurring costs of
implementing this bill year after year
will far exceed the cost of litigating
whether kl applies to new hampshire
and secondly
if
school districts are commanded by this
statute to increase the population they
have to serve without full state funding
there will be a lawsuit by the school
districts and that too will be expensive
the last point i want to raise is this
and it's the interface with the area
agencies
um
the uh and thank you for bearing with me
for this but that my my my letter
explains the tragedy that occurs with
the following scenarios and i've seen
multiple cases like this
recently
the new hampshire department of health
and human services has a policy
that if a student is in special ed then
adult services under rsa 171a are not
available
and so what we have is situations where
there are students older students in
special ed 18 19 20. uh their parents
raised them i mean these are kids who
have intellectual disabilities or autism
um their parents have raised them
since birth usually the dads bailed out
long ago
um the uh the child is now physically
larger than the mother
and um is out of control and the mother
or sometimes it's the grandmother um
who's been housing the child can no
longer deal with that child at home and
so what they do is they drop the child
at an emergency room
in a hospital or they just kick the
child out of the home
the child is homeless
now
um we have juvenile statutes that are
intended to protect children who are
neglected
but those statutes don't apply unless
the neglect petition is filed before the
child's 18th birthday
so we have no system to protect these
children that i'm just describing who
have passed age 18.
now
the school district does not have to
provide special education to them if
they're doing fine in their public high
school which is often the case the
school district has to provide a
residential placement when necessary for
the child to make meaningful educational
progress but i have multiple cases where
these children are doing fine in their
high school it's just that they have no
place to live because they've been
kicked out
of their homes
and school districts occasionally out of
sheer benevolence step in
and make a residential placement but the
residential placements they make have to
be
residential schools in massachusetts
which is very very restrictive and
unnecessarily expensive
the basic problem occurs because the
area agencies in the new hampshire
department of health and human services
are saying if you are in special ed
while you're in special ed you're not
entitled to residential services from us
we won't offer you a community-based
group home that would allow you to
attend the local public high school
which you've been attending all along we
won't offer you a community-based foster
home
and so um
if you are going to prolong eligibility
for special ad you are going to prolong
that tragedy by giving the area agencies
an extra year to run away from these
children which is scandalous
now the amendment begins to attack that
issue but really doesn't solve the
problem it says the provision of
services
um does not preclude the area agency
from
the provision of special ed does not
preclude the
area agency from
providing services but i i i'm
i'm not sure that that
gets us all the way we want to go it um
i'm putting myself in the position of
dhhs
and the area agencies they have their
policy if you're in special ed we won't
provide services until you're out of
special ed
and um
the the amendment seems to be saying
well the mere fact that you're
in special ed does not
preclude you from providing services
but does it require that they provide
services that's the question that i have
in my mind i would be much more
happy
that if
there was some more affirmative
statement
that the provision of special ed is not
a basis for dhhs and its area agencies
to refuse to provide services under rsa
171 a
when those services qualify under rsa
oh no
certainly so um next
first of all thank you very much for
your time i mean this turn this in my
mind anyway presents an entirely new
light on this issue that i was not and
unfortunately i didn't have a chance to
i didn't see your letter until just now
i i tried to skim through it quickly but
thank you very much it really turns an
entirely different light on this um i
just i guess i have a couple of
questions if i may
certainly uh first do you know uh the
the kl decision was that was there any
requests made by you know somebody in
that litigation either for rehearing in
banc or to go to the supreme court there
was not a petition for certiorari to the
supreme court there was a request for
rehearing on bonk and when i when i
learned of the decision i contacted
rhode island's lawyer and said
you didn't cite pennhurst
and he did file for onboard uh rehearing
but again did not cite penhurst
okay okay so all right and so that the
um
so the um
has uh has um
as far as you know has anyone
here in new hampshire said that there's
some
idiosyncratic
idiosyncrasy about the way new hampshire
treats
um special education that we have some
adult education law that allows people
to get
you know that they automatically are
qualify or something in some way that
that would be analogous to rhode island
well people have made noises about that
but when you ask them to be
uh specific
the ones that the specifics are when
you're looking at what is a state law or
state policy not what individual
adult education programs might do when
you look at state law the the states
the state board of education's rules
offer adult education
um
to the people who would qualify under
rsa
189 colon one and then 189 colon one is
a statute that requires school districts
to provide regular education until the
21st birthday
so um yet uh i don't i don't think
that's quite correct
well i'm i'm welcome to be correct it's
until you receive your degree
not until you're 21.
well well it's until
well new hampshire's regular ed statute
is until you reach age 21 or receive
your degree whichever occurs first yes
okay so it's it's
not
and frankly i would presume the way um
this
uh sb 394 is written when you look at it
in the context of other special ed laws
it would guarantee special ed until the
22nd birthday or receipt of a high
school diploma whichever occurs first
but with the population we're looking at
those severe disabilities
um if they haven't gotten diploma by age
20 if they haven't earned a diploma by
their 21st birthday then generally
they're not going to earn one by their
22nd birthday
i just had one other point of fiscal
point um
and i apologize for going on so long um
that's quite all right uh
when i looked at the fiscal impact
statements that accompanied these bills
they were very very flawed and the
reason why i say that
the children we're dealing with fall
into three categories
they're the ones who are attending their
local public high schools
but those kids can be very expensive i
had a case recently where
that child was getting what are called
transition services while the public
high school is costing the school
district eleven thousand dollars a month
for those transition services to
supplement the classes the child was
taking at the high school
and then there are students who because
of the severity of their disabilities or
the shortcomings of their high school
programs require placement in
specialized day schools um
and then
those are called out of district day
placements and then there are some
who um because of the uh
severity of their disabilities or the
lack of an appropriate day program
within commuting distance of home
are placed by school districts and
private residential schools which
generally tend to be schools in
massachusetts that'll cost 200 to 300
annually per child
now the um
the fiscal impact statement there's
there was a pair of bills 394 senate
bill 394 in house bill 1513.
one of them looked exclusively at the
children
in residential placements when coming up
with a fiscal impact statement
the other one looked at kids in
out-of-district placements both day in
residential schools outside their public
high school
when coming up with a fiscal impact
statement however neither fiscal impact
statement includes the children
who are receiving special education in
their local high schools even though
those children are very expensive now
perhaps the department of education has
shared with you information not in the
fiscal impact statements
that capture that population of special
education children who are attending
their local high schools
but the fiscal impact statements
themselves
um seriously understate the cost impact
uh representative petrie yeah thank you
madam chair thank you for being here uh
and uh you made us uh you had a white
paper in
early 2000 probably around 11
on kids falling off a cliff
and now we find that this community
services
that uh help with that
kids keep from falling up maybe they're
just falling off a hill now
but uh do you think the situation has
improved and you think this bill would
wouldn't uh
help the situation
well i i think this bill
i think this bill could hurt the
situation by um allowing the area
agencies to run away from these kids for
another year
um
my thought was the the long-term
solution
is for the benefit of the children
is to have
a study commission as one of the compa
the bills has it but to add to the study
commission's list of duties
to look at the relationship
between special education
and rsa 171-a
so that we have
smooth hand-offs and coordination i mean
here is one of the crazy ways the system
works okay um
school districts have to provide
transition services that are designed to
prepare children for life once they exit
special education
what often happens is that the school
district doesn't know
what the area agency is going to provide
when the child receives when the child
ages out of special ed so we are left in
the dark what transition services do we
provide will the child be in an adult
group home in manchester so we teach the
child how to navigate public
transportation there or will the child
be in a a a foster home in berlin where
instead we need to be teaching the child
how to navigate what's in berlin
and
then because of the
because the area agencies have been
underfunded
um
often what happens is when the child
ages out of special ed the area agency
offers
very little
um and so the district has then wasted
all this money
preparing the child for life as an adult
um with through transition services
and what we're preparing for is the
child to then fall off the cliff
when the area agency says we're not
going to provide services and it's not
because you've
you you were in special ed you've aged
out of special letters just because we
don't have enough money
what we have done is we used to have the
laconia state school
it was it served students of
served
adults with these disabilities of all
ages
it was a terrible place
we closed the laconia state school and
we enacted rsa 171a as a promise to
replace it with something better
and what we've done instead is
we fail to fully fund the better
and so we have a very
very poor system where if you're
within the age range for special ed
school districts are your social safety
net
um and if you're outside the age range
of special ed
you may get services under 171a you may
not and what you get under 171a if
you're getting any may be pretty um
maybe far less than what you deserve
uh i understand excuse me
i understand where you're coming from
okay
but i cannot fix hhs
okay i i cannot do
that that's what the health and human
services committee needs to do
they're the ones that
need to
direct or whatever you want to say
health and human service
to take care of these
people
and i will i will say
that
we have put a lot of money
into
these
services
in the last budget
and i don't know if it has improved or
not improved
but
hhs tells us they have no one
on the
what's it called the wait list
i don't know whether that's true or not
but
you know i'm just saying is i i cannot
solve the hhs problem
and that's why i think it's so important
that our
advocacy person
their office in
hhs
you know we we lost the
the lady that was doing it and doing a
really great job they've just appointed
somebody else that i've not met
but
i i just you know i can't solve that
problem i realize that okay but i i i
think we need to recognize that special
ed and 171a year like a water balloon if
you sign one side i i recognize that and
i am a big advocate for making sure
that the um
area agencies
don't let those folks drop off the table
well
my my modest suggestion is to just
include in the study commission uh uh
looking at we're eliminating the study
committee
okay okay all righty well yeah okay
representative heath
thank you madam chair your testimony
really conflicts with the guidance that
we were given on friday from the ag's
office um
the other issue that i just want to
raise is um i was an educator for a long
long time special educator as well
as well as being an administrator um
for non-disabled students
who might be turning 21 during their
senior year of high school
at any point during that year
we would let them finish when they turn
if their birthday was in december and
they turned 21 i know of no student that
we would put out of high school
until they graduated
so
for me
this amendment
solves so many issues
i too have been appalled by
i found out only by accident from one of
my students who was disabled
and a student
she said to me mrs heath i will not be
here tomorrow because my birthday is
today and i can't come to school anymore
which i must have called everybody in
the world to try and find out what i
could do for her and my answer
was i couldn't do anything this young
lady was a foster child she lived in a
group home she had to leave her group
home
and
people told me that she should have got
into it um there should have been better
communication between the k-12 world and
the adult world but
this amendment for me
begins the process it brings
more wholeness to the school district
in terms of the summer i ask the same
question what about summer programming
because that would be part of getting to
the cap so that would be included in the
funding um for this bill
i just seem like based on what the ag
said to us on friday that this seems
like the guidance that that we want to
incorporate within our legislation
for those students for students and
we're talking about a very very small
number of students
students that are placed at the
direction of the court
are different
um so we've got a whole lot of stuff
going on here but i just feel like this
amendment gets us one step
along the path
to getting those kids to where they need
to be and hopefully during that period
of time from 21 to 22 there is
an impetus for the area agency
the parents the group home or whoever to
work cooperatively so that in that
transition time the student does go
to something that is effective
and i mean i just am concerned that all
of a sudden after listening to the age
on vig's office on friday now we're
hearing something completely different
i'm sorry i
what i've been saying is it was in
letters that went to the house and
senate education committees it's not
something new
um
the ag's office represents a state
agency which you know
they have a certain interest in
protecting the state budget
perhaps at the expense of local budgets
i agree with the wisdom
of
allowing a child to complete the school
year
um
and many school districts do allow it
senator conn's bill originally proposed
exactly that
but then the uh
senate amended his bill
um to
uh instead uh take eligibility not until
the end of the school year during which
you reach your 21st birthday but all the
way to your 22nd birthday
so there are several different problems
we're trying to solve whether you're
going to be allowed to finish the school
year where some districts allow some
districts don't
um whether you're going to take it to
the 22nd birthday
um
whether
uh
you are
going to do it at the state's expense
or at the school district's expense
and whether in making that choice you're
complying with not only
some people's interpretation
of what federal law demands
but also the very clear provision in our
state constitution
uh represent lynn yes so i i guess i
have really two questions the first is
if um
if i understand correctly and correct me
if you interpret it if we were to pass
this
law or this bill
the amendment i'm sorry if we were to
pass this amendment
then school districts like for example
manchester as representative heath was
talking about that let a student who
turns 21 in december let's say finish
the school year under this a person who
turns 22 in december would be able to
finish the school year or i mean a
school district presumably if they did
it if they followed consistent practice
they'd say you can stay in school for
the rest of the year even after you're
22. is that would that follow they might
well do that i'd be surprised if they do
that but they might well do it yes all
right and the second may i ask a
follow-up second question i have is i
understand your concern about the last
sentence
uh which begins on line 17 of the
proposed amendment that it's sort of
wishy-washy in terms of what
it actually says
um uh
just uh when disability services needs
to be provided but i guess my concern
would be this
if this
language were
interpreted
to mean that disabilities that
developmental disability services
for which a student 21 years or of age
or older may qualify should be provided
and if dhhs is not
in other words if this was interpreted
to say between 21 and 22 you've got to
provide disability services and they're
not providing disability services for
students that are under 21 could that
create some equal protection problem
that you can't you can't just do this
for only the people between 21 and 22.
well that's a good question i mean i've
i've looked at the equal protection
problem with these social benefit
programs including for
uh
uh for education and um
the rational basis test applies when
it's equal protection unless there's a
suspect or semi-suspect class
and um age is not a suspect or
semi-suspect class it's why we have
social security but only if you reach a
certain age
and we have a variety of statutes that
are based on age and and they they
survived equal protection uh challenges
my my problem with this sentence and
mind you i've never seen this sentence
until just now uh and i'd love to have a
surprise none of us have it but if you
look at it on page 18 it's that that
pregnant term may qualify um so if the
area if the area agency is now saying
dhhs is positioned now it's not in a
rule and and their position is on appeal
to the new hampshire supreme court
um but they um and as new hampshire
superior court has held their position
as wrong but they haven't changed it
their position dhhs's position is that
if you're in in special ed you don't
qualify under 171a period
so if you use the term may qualify there
then i can easily see dhhs saying well
yeah only if you may qualify but you're
in special ed so you don't qualify and
of course you know i can argue that
that's
nonsensical but um it doesn't
it doesn't
with any level of assurance solve the
problem of that that tragedy i i
described
well
the uh i you know
right now
i believe you know you may qualify
all we're doing is upping the age
and it's not changing
the position of may qualify
because
you you qualify
for special ed
when you first enter school
you know and some people
get out some people don't
and
just because you happen to be
in special ed
doesn't necessarily mean that you
automatically qualify for
hhs services
you have to reapply
what the area agency
and the services that the area agency
provides
may in fact be totally different than
what
the school system was providing prior to
that so
it's it's uh
you know i don't know how i don't know
i don't know how we can change the word
may only because you may qualify or you
may not
based on whatever the rules are in hhs
well i suppose a more direct approach
offhand would be the uh to say that the
uh
something like the mere fact
that a child is receiving special
education shall not disqualify the child
for services under rsa 171 a
um thank you madam chair i still am
struggling where with the iep because
the iep is really the factor that drives
all of this
and wouldn't it be contingent upon the
iep
um
to really determine
that the ch
that identifies what should be happening
so
i i just am fearful of a shell
exactly as chair umber is saying that it
would cause
i think for the complications
i just don't underst i i
i'm just saying the mere fact that a
child qualifies for special ed shall not
disqualify the child
from whatever
the area agency would otherwise be
obligated to provide
and i actually
understand what you're saying
representative lynn
so i you know i th the language that you
propose i i agree that that would
that would sort of fix the problem but
my concern is that might really
fix too much in other words it might
it would i think would be interpreted to
mean
dhhs what you're doing now whether we go
forget about the age limit of the age of
the child what you're doing now
is wrong you should be providing
disability services when they're needed
for a child whatever age that whether
that's getting um uh
even if they are getting special
education services
and that might i'm not i don't know
whether i would agree with that or not i
tend to think i probably would agree
with it but
that's way beyond i mean that as
representative umbrella point out that's
a that's a
battle for a different day at a in a
different committee i think understood
it's it's momentous
if nothing else it just it underscores
um this is complex and the legislature
has never looked the legislature has
looked at these two stature stories
schemes as freestanding each in their
own silo
and
just like the agencies need to talk to
each other the legislature's policy
committees need to talk to each other
to coordinate these two systems so
they're not at war with each other and
so the transition services the districts
are spending their money on and
the legislature's money on
are services that that prepare the child
for life as an adult when the child as
an adult will be under the umbrella of
the area agency
i'm sorry to make it such a big picture
on a little it's quite all right we we
love to hear the other side
uh representative petry
thank you madam chair
uh
on the 28a issue
all right
of people in state prison do not have a
high school education or equivalent
so it's a pay me now pay me later
so
where do you stand i mean it's
you're going to have to pay and if we
don't have educated people we're
you know we're going to pay at some
point
yeah the 28a issue is not whether you
pay it's just who pays it's it's it's if
if le
it's re it's been characterized by the
new hampshire supreme court with like a
bean counting orientation that it makes
it difficult for school districts to
budget
i i think it's it's more profound it
it's saying um
to the legislature if you have a vision
of social justice
then
um
you
need to come up with the money out of
your own budgets
to finance that vision
uh because then you take the credit but
you also take the blame
and
you know to take it
i i don't mean to be on a soap box here
but the foundations of democracy
a healthy democracy are transparency and
accountability
representatives who are elected need to
be accountable
um and to the voters and one way to be
accountable is you know the voters look
at the budgets they look at their taxes
and and when
the the heart of 28a
is
that those who enact the laws should be
accountable for the financial
consequences of those laws because
otherwise it's a shell game where the
legislature enacts the laws but avoids
the blame for any
poor decisions it's made regarding
whether the law was worth it
um because the legislature passes the
costs on
to the municipality
and the local
townspeople are confused they don't know
who to blame
don't blame me
okay thank you very much i i appreciate
it and um
i i appreciate your viewpoint
um
and uh and i think it uh it helps us to
understand and i totally agree with you
that
the policy committees should talk to
each other
you know
i probably
i probably talk more to
the policy committees
than
the policy committees talk to each other
but that's neither here nor there so
thank you very much um
diana you wanna i thank you very much i
apologize for all the time i took
appreciate your listening to me that's
no problem
we have
you're welcome we have all day
good morning my name is diana fenton i'm
an attorney with the department of
education in large part i'm here to
answer the committee's questions
and i cannot testify directly for
attorney chris bond who is on vacation
right now but my understanding and i
don't work for the attorney general's
office and i want to be clear about that
but i think
attorney bond's testimony has been
consistent throughout this legislative
session as it pertains to this bill
and the other the house bill that is the
the twin of this the 1513 i believe
there is a strong concern
that if this amendment is not passed if
the language is not changed that the
state will be subject to a lawsuit
and that has been consistent that
testimony has been consistent and it has
been clear
and again i'm not here to testify for
the attorney general's office i don't
work for that agency
but that has been their interpretation
and
that has been their testimony so i feel
comfortable referring this committee to
that prior testimony
i think that um certainly i have argued
before representative lin in his prior
capacity and in my prior capacity
and every case is
factually different
and we don't know how that case will
arise
but in looking at our law and looking at
the rhode island case there are enough
similarities to cause the state
pause
to cause to cause the state to say
we feel that there will be a lawsuit and
it is troubling and we have an
obligation to look out for the state
interest and our state funds and to
protect um against that so
again i'm um
playing the role of chris bond who is on
vacation today um and i'm happy to take
any questions
so i i i have no doubt
that there would be a lawsuit but that
i'm not sure that that should be the end
of the matter i mean i mean i guess what
i'm
what i'm wondering is and i as i say
this is brand new to me i haven't
researched this looked at this at all
but can you tell me do you know at all
for um from speaking with mr bond is
this first circuit case you know is this
just one case cases all over the country
all the other circuits are a substantial
number of them have all said no you have
to provide education services to age 22
or do we have one circuit court that you
know in a split decision
based on the specific
rationale of the rhode island law
said no you have to do this
so um
thank you for the question this this is
very familiar to me uh representative
lynn we've done this before haven't we
in a different form
my understanding is the crux of the
analysis is based on that rhode island
case that kl case and
i understand it's one case it's a first
circuit case i am not aware of of other
cases that are kind of
following that domino effect um but in
my reading of the kl case and my
interpretation of it and speaking with
other attorneys it's very compelling
and the facts are very similar to the
new hampshire law we heard from
attorneys allen about the you know the
differences between the two but in
looking at it new hampshire's law
aligns quite carefully with rhode
islands
so
you know whether there will be a lawsuit
sure their lawsuits about all sorts of
things
but the analysis from the attorney
general's office goes beyond whether or
not there will be a lawsuit
obviously
and i think the testimony has been about
what the result of that lawsuit will be
and that's what is concerning and
troubling
how about non-legal questions
oh good we'll we'll see
so what about let's assume there's a
lawsuit and we lose uh or i mean there's
a lawsuit and there's expenses involved
in the lawsuit if if we just do this
as i unders what do you say about mr
zelen's concern about the long-term
expenses
of doing something that
uh of providing for uh for lack of a
better term another year
of special education services that we
might not have to provide
that's a very good question a very tough
question
um
and i'm not sure exactly how to answer
that but i think based upon the concerns
that we've identified
um of of a lawsuit and the costs that
would come from that lawsuit and a lot
of people have spent an enormous amount
of time creating this amendment which
the belief is would
solve that issue
and address all the concerns um
i think the amendment before you solves
that problem to uh to the best of our
abilities and does so in a financially
appropriate way
thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thanks for taking
the question of following up on
representative lynn um although i think
uh you believe that this would solve the
potential for a lawsuit similar to the
rhode island case
um it was
the testimony was given that
by not properly funding from the state
level and the downshifting costs that we
would be subjected to
potential or almost guaranteed
litigation
on that end so my question would be is
if we did nothing
just assuming i'm not saying we're doing
it we did nothing right now and we had a
lawsuit similar to
rhode island and we prevailed in that
case
what would be the
long-term negative effects
uh
from not doing this
this
the bill or the amendment is it was that
clear on that uh yes i believe you were
very clear so
you're changing the hypothetical uh just
a bit to say we're talking hypothetical
seriously that's right i'm used to it so
the hypothetical is there's
no action is taken the lawsuit ensues
and the state
state wins um
perhaps that limits the financial
liability but there would still be that
lawsuit
um and with that comes time and money
and perhaps there will be lawsuits no
matter what that's what lawyers do
um but again i
i will direct this committee to the
consistent testimony that has been given
on this bill
and the
functional equivalent in the house
and it's uh it's a rare time where you
get consensus by a lot of state
attorneys
saying that there is a strong concern
and a strong likelihood is not that
there will be a lawsuit there are
lawsuits all the time over everything
but that
the state will lose
and i would strongly encourage this
committee to look at that testimony and
to really listen to those words
that chris bond has expressed on behalf
of the attorney general's office
i would be remiss if that were to
go without emphasizing that concern that
not only will the state be sued but that
there is a strong likelihood that the
state would would not be successful in
such litigation but i say with the
caveat that every case is different and
it would depend on the facts
represent murray
thank you again i apologize i wasn't
here this this past friday um and i'm
hearing so much around this legal talk
and so help me out because
it's when i'm looking at this build
isn't it the right thing to do on the
behalf of these children and isn't the
concern how we benefit the children
whether or not we're
all the legal stuff to me is somewhat
secondary to compared to
the helping these kids who apparently
need this extra funding of this extra
year so i just i feel like i'm on a
different track from all the other
discussions that i'm hearing here
are there any other questions
was that a sigh or was that that was a
sign i'm not sure that it's a question
ever since i've been working on budgets
here several several of these budgets
i've heard these same arguments
and and it always came
it had to do with
um
funding the
the wait list for this disability
and we we did get sued for not fully
funding that
and i thought that after this past
budget cycle
where we
did fund
all of the wait list that that had all
been taken care of and and now i'm
hearing the same arguments are coming
back
again am i getting that wrong or am i
oh no representative bucco that's
absolutely correct
because that was
that was a problem
and
i think that
what happens is that
as
the young adults
trans transition from
high schools
to
dhhs
services that
they may not
be the same
and that's where
that's where
the problem is but that is
way outside
of what we're looking at here we're just
trying to make sure
that
the school system and
dhhs
work together
to
do something
after they age out of school
yes representative thank you thank you
madam chair um i think ultimately
we want to afford the children with
disabilities
the same courtesy that we would provide
to their non-disabled peers
and if a child is 21 years old
and wanting to finish high school
we let them
for the most part
and
for child with a severe disability
to be within our school system and to
have to suddenly disappear from the
ranks at the age 21
it just it poses so many difficulties
for the family for the school district
for the child himself
and yes it needs to be a better
transition from the school district to
the adult
um agency
and the law says that i don't know what
else we can do to make it more real
but i just feel like this amendment gets
us to where we need to be
based on the testimony that we heard
from the attorney from the attorney
general's office and from the department
who i heard and if i'm wrong please
correct me that that there are people
lining up to protest
um the fact that children need to leave
school at 21 in this particular
circumstance
that is true
are there any further questions for miss
fenton
did you have a question no
i want to move uh
amendment 2022
oh certainly
no it's quite all right we
we just love all this stuff that
gets our juices rolling no you do
why we start every day
with this so so
so thanks thanks very much madam chair
members of the committee for the record
again dave luna
uh hopkins concord and serving on the
house education committee um uh there's
been great testimony this morning i
think it's been really helpful i i hate
to disagree
with my my um
great friend from manchester and and
friend from newcastle but i'm concerned
that this amendment doesn't actually do
what what you'd like it to do which is
to protect
school districts who did not budget for
students going through age 22 during fy
23 because most these districts held
their meetings back in march and
approved those budgets and i think as
all of us know
a
a school district budget is a bottom
line budget
and
funds from things like capital reserve
funds like special education capital
reserve fund
aren't there to exceed the budget they
can come in as funds to fund the budget
you know in lieu of local
property taxes um but uh but they can't
be used to exceed the budget and
well my my my belief is that they can't
be used to exceed the budget what
what um
um
what
what most districts have been what some
districts let me say have been able to
do
is um is is
when uh when a district has a let's say
two or three percent undesignated fund
balance is reappropriate from one line
to another line but we've seen a number
of districts tighten up on on budgets
and the amount of undesignated fund
balance that would be anticipated going
into the following year tends to be less
and less and less so it may not be
sufficient
to accommodate
a you know a change in policy requiring
students to or allowing students to
to continue in school through
through age 22. that's um
that's my my uh my first concern um that
that the amendment doesn't doesn't
actually address it because it's very
clear from the amendment that that it
comes in to backfill in the following
year so so
but but talking about availability of
funds
for school districts in fy 23 it doesn't
provide for that and i don't believe
capital reserve funds
are going to be able to use that to over
over extend to extend over their their
their budget
the um uh the second um point excuse me
did you look at the latest uh fiscal
note
i haven't seen the all i have is the
amendment i haven't seen it oh okay
because the latest fiscal note says
six children with disabilities turning
21 during the current school year
right we had we had testimony to that
that's what
that's the number of students that we're
looking at
um
and then
nine children with disabilities
during the next school year which is
22-23
so
um but
yes right the school board has the right
to take the money out of
a capital reserve account
as
they have to vote on it obviously
uh in order to
fulfill
shortages in whatever
the capital reserve is yeah i i believe
that's only revenue shortages and not to
over not to extend beyond the budget but
i don't i'm that's you know
um
12 years on a school board eight years
chair and um and and i i've i've never
seen our ability to to go beyond what uh
what the what the voters uh approved as
a bottom line budget
at our at our march meetings um that
that said um i'm also concerned
about the um the number of of students
that would be affected by by this policy
i believe it's probably more than than
four or six and we do have 186 students
that are currently
over 20 years old
and have not received their um their
high school diploma so this likely over
time will apply to them as they as they
reach the age of of 22.
and and i think a a question that we
also had that was not satisfactorily
answered in um in house education was
what impact does this have on um on on
homeschoolers who are also efa students
in the state will they will they be
eligible to to receive the their their
their state efa because that's all
state
state money
um
uh will they be able to receive that
those payments from the state through
their through their 22nd uh birthday and
um and i think that's an open question
the uh the answer we heard in in
committee was that nope efa students are
done at age 18. but when taking a look
at the statute 194f it does not
terminate the the efa account for that
student at age 18. so i believe they
would continue to qualify
just as any student would for a um for a
right for public education according to
189 colon 1-a
which
which currently is is through age 21 or
until you receive your
your high school diploma and um and i
think it's questionable as to what what
you know how how this would apply to um
to home um uh schooling students so
those are really the um i'm
homeschooling students with a with an
efa so those are really my only two
thoughts it was clear in house education
that uh that that this bill i think
lacked a comprehensive um
financial review that that i think the
legislature should be entitled to and um
and i think that was really the the the
concern that uh that we had and are
hopeful that uh that the finance
committee is going to uh is going to
look for that type of comprehensive
report i think that was part of the
reason why
why why we did put a study committee on
it but i certainly i certainly
understand removing the study committee
as long as a comprehensive analysis of
how changing this policy would ripple
through
um obligations for um uh for local
taxpayers as well as the state
are there any questions
if i didn't know better i would say that
you're recommending itl
um
i would
i would i would
you know personally madam chair i would
proceed very cautiously um with this
and and um and you know i don't i
certainly cannot um uh speak for
attorney bond
um um i i think um attorney fenton did
uh did a did a good job
at um
uh at summarizing his um
um his testimony that we heard in house
education it may be worth taking a look
at that that video and um uh in hearing
from that i have in my notes here next
to attorney bond's testimony uh that new
hampshire may be different from rhode
island
and and i think he may have said that
but i don't want to you know put words
into his mouth on um uh on that
um
uh and and i think there's certainly a
number of other areas that attorneys
allen has um has brought up that that go
well beyond my um
you know competency in this in this area
you know in terms of a note of caution
and so so that's um
that's all i'd really like to leave with
the committee
well maybe more of a comment i just
very quickly looked up online uh
the uh the the kl decision and i would
just note because i think it at least is
somewhat important that the dissent in
the case was written by
by judge lynch former chief judge of the
first circuit a clinton appointee very
very well respected so it seems to me
that you know
she may have been wrong i haven't
studied it she may have been wrong but
this is not like you know this is this
is some you know insubstantial person
who wrote a crazy descent and uh and we
have we don't have to worry about it
that's i'm very
confident that that's not the case so
the uh the you know she may be wrong the
majority may be right we might lose if
there was another lawsuit but
i don't think that
um it can just be assumed that we you
know that that's that it that the
majority was definitely
all correct
represent the heath
madam cheer um could we hear from
disability rights um please i think it
would be nice to hear from the other
side as well as legislators for folks
who represented
okay absolutely thank you
great thank you very much okay thanks
steve
thank you
for the record my name is karen
rosenberg i'm an attorney with the
disability rights center i'm also the
policy director
so i wanted to
answer some questions that have been
raised here one from representative lin
about what other circuit courts have
weighed in on this decision and for your
information the second circuit court of
appeals and the ninth circuit court of
appeals have also issued similar
decisions and cases challenging states
failure to provide
a free appropriate public education to
students with disabilities until they
the day before they turned 22.
and um
this um the connecticut the decision
from the second circuit arose out of
connecticut and it was decided last
summer
so it's a pretty it's a very recent
decision affirming this point and in
terms of the facts and new hampshire's
provision of adult education compared to
rhode islands it's quite similar
actually
what the first circuit held is that
there are basically three criteria to
look at to determine whether states must
provide an appropriate education for
students with disabilities until they
turn 22 those have to do with
a mandate that they do it we have such a
mandate and and in
new hampshire law that adult education
be provided that there be oversight from
a state body which we have our state
department of education oversees the
provision of adult services and that the
services be subsidized with state and
federal funds which also occurs in new
hampshire
we provide significant funding through
wioa the workforce
initiative innovative opportunities act
and also state funds to fund adult
education in this state one distinction
that i believe one of the senators
attempted to draw had to do with whether
students who are adults have to pay
anything out of pocket
and
actually in rhode island students who
are pursuing an adult diploma do pay out
of pocket a portion of the cost of
securing an adult diploma so that's
similar because in new hampshire some
students also would pay in new hampshire
we do not charge students for
preparation courses to secure the hiset
which is our high school equivalency
exam i believe in rhode island they
actually do charge
some programs do charge for students to
secure a high set so
there is a there are a lot of
similarities between how we operate our
programs in new hampshire and how the
adult education programs operated in
rhode island and like i said other
circuits have come to this conclusion
also it should be noted that the
overwhelming majority of states do
provide special education services for
students beyond their 21st
birthdays
so i hope that answers some questions i
don't know if you have
other questions about the developmental
services system or how um
you know this interplays with that or
they're related
thank you and please don't be shy if you
want to speak you don't have to be asked
you just you just have to
you know say i'd like to speak thanks
i'm still new at this position oh thank
you for the invite yeah any any time
we're
especially on division two we're pretty
we're pretty open
and
let folks talk if they need to thank you
okay
you may ask a question in the second and
ninth circuit cases were they unanimous
decisions or any dissent you know i
don't recall i'm sorry okay thank you
do you did you have a question represent
murray or is this just the heading no
i'm just thinking um but yeah if i may
if you don't mind madam chair can you
again you know i wasn't here the other
one um just speak to
the problem that this is attempting to
solve this gap between when you're 21
and you have to leave school
but
other things haven't kicked in yet
because you're not 22 can you just give
a little scenario for what is the
supposing what is this solving so
there's i think they're actually two
separate concerns here
what this solves is bringing new
hampshire's
law in terms of eligibility for special
education in line with federal law
so i think that's a separate concern
from what you're talking about where
students especially students with
developmental disabilities
are
experiencing difficulty in their
transition to what we call adult
services
and those are the services that are in
place not for every student but for
adult students who have certain
developmental disabilities who require
habilitation services services to help
them be successful
in their homes and communities that
aren't necessarily that are not
education services
and
um
as
represent as um attorney zelen referred
to there's um currently a lawsuit that
my office brought to
secure a decision
that
those services developmental services
ought to be provided under our state law
from the time when a student with a
developmental disability is eligible for
them regardless of whether they are in
school or out of school
so
um
that's a gap that we're trying to
address and there's actually a bill um
that may come before you i think maybe
not maybe it's division three sb430 that
creates a pilot program to start
providing some state funds for students
between the ages of 18 and 21 who are
still enrolled in school the position
that the department of health and human
services has taken is that when students
are in school and over 18 that they are
not entitled to developmental services
we disagree with that
did that answer your question
it's helping me
if you have more it's okay
i talk fast
represent bucco
thank you madam chair
um
the this latest um
fiscal note
amendment dated 422
and the only change that i see is it
says that the students between the ages
of 3 and 21 inclusive
and that i think that
covers what you just said what the
that's that mirrors the language in the
federal law idea the individuals with
disabilities education act
thank you
are there any
further comments caitlyn did you have
your hand raised or no
[Music]
is there any
uh
mr zelen
just note that this little note
the latest one
is is limited to
uh students in residential placements
being shown
um
and in addition as i flip the page
in addition to those in separate schools
um but still omits
those who are attending local public
high schools
who can be very expensive when their
transition services might be eleven
thousand dollars a month
but i guess that might account for
representatives lunos figure of 186
students who might be impacted by this
bill versus the lower number of students
interested in physical knowledge i think
that um
rebecca ferdet may have secured some
updated numbers but also i think it's
really important to keep in mind that
we're not talking about an unfunded
mandate here because this is a federal
mandate so it's not subject to our
constitutional prohibition against
unfunded mandates
and
not not to mention we are funding it
right
okay thank you
thank you very much it was nice nice
meeting you and uh hope that you'll have
lots of fun here i am thank you
just just like we do every day
uh representative turcotte thank you
madam chair just a uh clarification
anybody wants to talk about it
but in a lot line 11 of the amendment
where it talks about uh towards the end
over age 21 to age 22
it was my understanding that the intent
of what we're trying to accomplish
is to
ensure an individual who starts
school at age 21 turns 22 during that
school year
is covered through the remainder of that
as i read this i could certainly
interpret the way it is written now i
think somebody may even mention this
before
that over age 21 to age 22
are we now opening ourselves to
somebody who starts school at age 22 and
continuing on past that
somebody just mentioned
the federal
language which uses the term inclusive
um
so as written i'm not so sure this is
yes go ahead
go ahead come on up
thank you so
no it would not require schools to keep
a student in school beyond their 22nd
birthday and that's okay
i mean i think some people think that
that may not be okay for a student first
of all it does mirror the federal law
but also as a practical matter students
who are in school beyond their 21st
birthday or even beyond their 20th
birthday are really focusing on
transition to adult services and a lot
of the time they don't have those same
connections to the brick and mortar
building
because they're getting their services
in like job coaching and job training
and internships and learning how to do
laundry and maintain an apartment and
use public transportation and all those
kinds of things
so
it's just something that you plan for so
that student if the student really is
attached to the flow of the school then
that student if it's right for them
could choose to leave at the end of the
prior school year
or if they are really getting some
um very
beneficial community-based services then
they would continue those services
knowing that when they turn 22 they'll
be fully transitioning to second
secondary post-secondary services sorry
i understand exactly
what you are interpreting the intent to
be what i'm saying is as i read this i
could certainly and i think other people
could probably make an argument that
um this would now extend instead of as
it's currently written
written to age 21 and as representative
heath says they don't kick their people
out and they go through the end of that
school year
i believe an attorney could make an
argument that well it says 22 now
so let's push that out an additional
year well so you're you're referring to
the amendment or you were because the
actual language talks about inclusive no
i'm talking about the amendment so
well
i'm i don't share your concern but if
you were really concerned about that you
could um
just use like you could change the
language to something like um
through the age of 21 or until their
22nd birthday or something if you're
really nervous about it but honestly i'm
i'm not nervous about it
but i'm not your lawyer
by the way we don't have a lawyer
[Laughter]
um we have mickey and he can't i
understand what you're saying i i
totally get it but um
i have been
jotting down some more language because
i do not think it is specific enough to
what we're trying to do but that's my my
opinion
well we we certainly
um if that
seems to be a problem we could say
uh
[Music]
over
age 21
inclusive is that the term inclusive and
i think
since the intent is to complete the
school year almost which
i don't think i'm sorry i'm interrupting
you well that's that's what has been
relayed here to me i'm new at this game
so i'm you know
but that has been the
uh
since we're talking about education
and to me that has to deal with
school years and
representative heath is very well versed
in this and that's what i'm getting from
her
i hear what you're saying but i don't
think that's what the intent is because
if that was the intent
to extend to mandate
schools to educate
students with disabilities beyond their
22nd birthday then i might actually
agree with um attorneys ellen that there
would be an unfunded mandate no that's
not that's not what i'm suggesting i'm
just suggesting that the intent of the
bill is a student who's 21
who turns 22 during the school year is
indeed eligible to finish that school
year that's the way
i this whole discussion has centered
around not
and what i'm saying is i believe this
just opens it up so i would at some
point if we approve this i think it
needs to be well clarified a little bit
we'll fix it but
if you're not and
i i don't know what the right words are
but we may you know
that
district cost providing service special
education
students
and says over age 21 until the their
22nd birthday or until the end of the
school year if that was a good point no
we it wasn't until the school year no
it's the 22nd birthday
until
their 22nd birthday
i think that would match what the
federal law provides because it
if school districts want to be you know
extra generous that's on them really um
it's nice but it may not be it's not
necessary in terms of compliance with
the federal law
until the birth
[Music]
do we do we want to say until their 22nd
birthday
okay
i i mean i hate to be in the position to
advocate for less for people with
disabilities it really it does seem
awful but i but i really need to you
know be real with you so the federal law
doesn't require it we always want people
to be real
okay
thank you anything else
so
mickey will do his magic
and um
are we all set with the um the section
about
the um
adult services
i think so
i think you were okay with that right
i don't believe sorry rebecca fernett i
don't believe that adult services
specifies an age of 21 i believe it says
until they graduate or exit school what
it says here a provision of such
services
does not preclude adult development
disability services for which a student
over 20 years of age may qualify
that's that's i want to make
that's the language that we need to
address that if in fact that the child
is 21 finishing the school year whatever
service is finishing um that they are
entitled
for that transition into the adult
services as well is that making sense
so
um here's here's where we get to that
lawsuit that drc has that's on appeal to
the new hampshire supreme court
so in
the case that where we prevailed in
superior court the court held that
students who are over 18 years of age
who also are eligible for developmental
services
are eligible to receive those services
when they're in school if they're not
services that are the responsibility of
the school district
and
you know in transparency this is this is
now the the state department of health
and human services is appealing that
decision
but that is our view that there are
students who should not be forced out of
school
in order to secure services from the
developmental services system and that
they need perhaps like residential
supports that they may not require to
get an appropriate education
well voc rehab is another service that
students could receive i
i did sort of wordsmith a little
something with um attorney zelen that he
might feel better about in terms of
addressing this issue which we could
share
if
you wanna
we would love to share
what did you do did you keep it okay
so
that that i did
a little wordsmithing and ran it by um
attorneys allen to
sort of restructure this in a way that
would
make it clear that students who qualify
for developmental disability services
could secure those services if they're
not required for the student to receive
a free appropriate public education
and
the way that i crafted it was to
basically capture all adult students
like i said this is something that is
currently being appealed about whether
this applies to all adult students
whether you know we think it should or
whether you want to take a narrower
approach and only have it
something like this apply to students
who are over 21 of course we want it
we agree that it would be better to um
just have this provision kind of cleared
up in terms of adult students securing
the services they're entitled to so
my beautiful handwriting yes i i
understand that but
this bill is dealing with the 21
age
and so
that other issue is an hhs h.a what we
could do is issue
yes
20 make it 21 and
we'll try to
try to propose something like that i'm
just looking at this for the first time
um
just two minutes ago i just wrote it
three minutes ago
yeah and and maybe that
some like if you were interested in it
um
it's not perfect i think it's um
the closest we could come up
the best we could do now under these
circumstances
how about if i give you an hour
but my
okay all right i'll be quiet let's work
on okay
yeah okay
so uh
let us uh
let us um
go off to lunch and
we'll be back at one o'clock
and yes i thought this was very simple
but obviously even the easiest things
are difficult
so okay mickey you do not have to run
and do an amendment
okay
all right see you back at one
oh
okay i'll call us back
to whatever order
and we'll continue work on
sb 394
when we left a couple of our friends
were going to work on some language
to replace uh the last sentence
in
the amen not the last sentence but uh
lines 17 and 18 and then 19.
and
um
i i appreciate it
and um
i just like to read
what they said
i guess they want this as a new
paragraph
yeah okay
um
a student's receipt
of special education services
under rsa
186-c
shall not affect whether such student
may simultaneously
receive developmental
disability services which they may be
eligible to receive
under rsa 171
dash a
you you want to come up
i don't care which one both
well we all want what's best for kids
yeah
so
sure just just one question where does
this
language be start on the in the bill
okay what they're doing is
they're they're making that last
sentence right
number two
oh okay okay okay and then
and then that
not number
not exactly what we decided was that it
might be it would make more sense to
move it up into the body of the bill so
that's so so so if you look at the
the bill as
amended by the house
what this would do is it does two things
it would okay the only thing that we're
discussing is the amendment right
it is the amendment okay okay so but
instead of having it
so what
so the the issue had to do with that
last sentence in the proposed amendment
right
so
what we thought made more sense was to
um
take out that last line from the
proposed amendment
but move the concept
that that that that line was attempting
to achieve
to
further up in the body of the bill so if
you have the bill in the bill in front
of you
as passed by the house
it would create a new it would be
incentive where do you want it so in in
the original in the bill that was passed
section one okay forget the bill that
passed
well that
we're only talking about the amendment
right so this amendment would just it's
this is what the language would be we
just felt that a more appropriate place
to put the amendment would be
in the
in under you know when you're talking
about eligibility and the bill would
just it would just amend the bill and
then you keep your amendment
but just strike the last sentence and
that's not what you had in mind no
the amendment replaces the entire bill
i think that section two
by replacing all after section one right
so so the amendment is just section two
right and then the bill what we propose
to do is put this concept in section one
because it kind of keeps all the
eligibility stuff together okay so
you're seeing
at the end of
section one
which we didn't eliminate
right you would you would add this
concept
right
and then if you did that
then you still keep the amendment that
you are proposing with the one exception
that you would just
note you would no longer need the last
line of what is in the
proposed amendment roman numeral one
so you could just strike that last line
okay okay right because we've taken care
of that concept by moving it up to under
eligibility
and does that make sense now it does
and our rationale was
that we
that that sentence that um
we're removing if we left it where it
was it would be linked to just one
school year
and we wanted to have
that that sentence
relating to the children
with developmental disabilities
modify the whole scheme
not just the uh the whole harmless
clause pertaining to that one school
year and then and we tried the language
that we're proposing
uh we tried to make as neutral as
possible so we didn't tilt the tables
one way or another in terms of whether
the
area agency would have a duty to
children who are still receiving special
ed we thought we just let the supreme
court decide that
and we
didn't want to create any legislative
history
that would have any impact on that case
okay does everybody get that other than
me who was uh like
totally something else
tom oops sorry represent buca thank you
madam chair
if we're leaving section one
it it already contains language that
says between the ages of 3 and 21
inclusive i thought that was the
intent of trying to change the language
that language is already there
right no the the language that we're
replacing is in the amendment
online
17 18 and 19.
provision of such services does not
preclude adult development
disability services
that's that's going away
okay okay
but this
will go up here
under paragraph one
i got it
under paragraph one yeah so it would be
a new it would be a paragraph roman two
uh oh okay
yeah right okay i thought it was i
thought you were leaving one and putting
in
okay thank you
i mean i i think i could sum up the
effects of what we're doing yeah it's
okay i think we understand the effect
and
can i answer your question about that
certainly i understand what you
want to do
but i guess as i read this a student's
receipt of special education services
under 1 186 c
shall not affect whether such student
may may simultaneously receive some
developmental service but
by saying that isn't the isn't
the way dhhs is now
operating
it does affect it the fact that the
student is receiving
is receiving special education services
means they can't get these services so
if we say this haven't we ascend i mean
you may not have intended this but
haven't we said in effect you're like
you don't need a lawsuit you won well
we really you know that would have been
just like awesome if we could have done
that but we knew that was not that we're
really fair to do that so what we think
that this does though is it says that
it acknowledges that they have to be
eligible to receive those services so
there are actually some services that
students even like under 18 years old
that are developmental services that
they are entitled to receive even though
they're receiving special ed services so
there are some that there's not even a
debate about so for example we have an
in-home supports waiver for kids who are
i believe it's up to 21 right now
for that's more limited than what our
developmental disabilities waiver
provides
so student and those students receive
those in-home supports and they go to
school and they and there's no debate
even about that that really what that
means where the debate is is
what at what age
is a student eligible to receive
developmental services under our
developmental disability waiver program
it's a medicaid it's a medicaid waiver
program and so by using the word um
developmental services which they may be
eligible to receive
really kind of leaves it up to
the decision makers at this point it's
going to be the new hampshire supreme
court about when a student who is
enrolled in school is eligible no it's
not up to the supreme court it's up to
hhs
well there's a case before the supreme
court there may be though okay there may
be but that's not
well i just just i mean i i agree that
the term weather
you can interpret it one way and you
could interpret it in another way uh and
i think our intent
would be uh to clarify it by saying
shall not of fact one way or the other
weather all right so can i give you guys
ask a follow-up uh
listen i think all of us non-legal
people
need to leave the room
and let you guys
please don't leave we need you
let you guys figure this out go ahead
but so my question i guess is this if
you want if if you want to leave it up
to the supreme court
to you know what whatever they're do i
mean if if if dhs is wrong in what in
the way they're doing and you may be
absolutely right i mean i as i you know
without getting into the whole details
of it it sounds like you've got a pretty
good argument that you think so you won
in this period right so if you're so if
you're right
then why do we need to do why do we need
to to either have this amendment or even
have the language in provision of such
services why don't you just take both of
those out and
you know if you're right you'll win your
lawsuit and this and the state will have
to provide those services up through
age 22.
well
i think i'm not sure we're going to see
eye to eye on this i think it would be
okay to not to do what you're talking
about um because it does purely leave
everything up to
you know who is now going to be the
decision maker i'm not sure that my
colleague would feel the same way
because i think there's a concern that
area agencies aren't
doing what they need to be doing for
students with developmental disabilities
so i i don't want to speak for you but i
think but as i've said we cannot solve
that problem
yeah
and that's why we specifically tried to
make it as even-handed as possible yeah
um so right well as as i'm trying to
rerun the reel here today i think what
we're proposing was a reaction to
mary's good intention of putting in
that last sentence
of her proposed amendment and our
concern was that that last sentence
might be misinterpreted
as just creating an exception for one
school year
so i'm i think
offhand that representative lynn is
correct
and that the better thing to do is just
scratch the amendment
i mean by scratching your members
just you could just you could remove the
last sentence and that would have saved
us you know 50 minutes of drafting for
you
no no no just get rid of that last
no no no just that less you need you
need the amendment for funding to defray
the cost to the school districts but you
could take out that last sentence
um which i i i understand the intent
here but it's but it seems like it may
be more problematic than it's worth just
clarification when you say you you don't
we can we can delete this handwritten
amendment you can shred that you can get
rid of that yes you can get rid of the
handwritten
all you need to all you need to do is
and take out the last section the last
sentence exactly lines 17 and 18. so it
just clears up any ambi what what i
think there was such a good intent here
but it creates a lot of ambiguity about
eligibility for developmental services
and so
you came of course you came up with the
cleanest way to deal with the ambiguity
um which would be just to remove it and
then we'll see what the new hampshire
supreme court does and um
yeah
and that
i i think i think that's probably the
easiest thing to do you'd go with that
yeah
representative heath are you okay with
that
turn your mic on
my understanding i was thinking what i
was going to say
my understanding then is that
this amendment now
for
the 22-23 school year
and the completion
we've got two school years here we've
got 22 and then we're going to have 23.
so for the completion of 22 and for the
department of ed
we're all of 23
okay
but and 22 as well
yeah well the school year starts in
september which is still 22. okay
right right so that there will be
funding
for those students
and the concern that was raised was this
would in senator khan's amendment was
that this would negate their ability to
access
sir adult services
and so we're going to be silent on that
well yeah i see what you're saying
so was it okay to be silent on that
i mean we were concerned that if we
aren't definitive
that
a school and the services say we don't
have to do anything until yeah you know
what i hear you
go back
well i mean but
just a minute
the way this amendment has written its
own that that state that last line is
only good for this 22 23 school year yes
okay yes and so
i don't it doesn't belong there anyway
yeah that that's my i would agree with
that
but i'm not sure
that we
should add this
i mean because
the way the way the um
the way the system is supposed to work
okay we don't want to let them off the
hook well they
the way it's supposed to work is
when they reach whatever age it is
and they graduate from high school
then it's a transition it's
it's all that part of
you know the transition which i which
hhs is supposed to pick up because it
shouldn't it shouldn't just say oops i'm
21 end of school year and now
somebody talked to me from adult
services that conversation should have
been going on and i and i agree and i
think that what i've heard
is that it is going on
and
[Music]
you know it may not be up to
where we think it should be
but at least in many cases it is going
on
okay
this is a really tough nut to crack
because you've got these two different
systems
that but one child who needs services
how do we make it work
well
i think that that would be something for
legislation next year
okay how do we make it work
okay we've been trying for how many
years well i i'm just saying that
if you know that's the kind of
legislation i believe that we need for
next year so
and i'll i'll sign on good so this one
means that
susie smith
can stay in school because her
birthday's in october and she can stay
till the end of the school year or she
gets stages he's 22
right
but probably it'll be the end of the
school year because then hopefully the
adult services will take her once once
she once she once she leaves school
whether that's when she's 18 or 22
that's one thing that's not up for
debate we know that when she exits
school that developmental services must
kick in what's up what's right now
in flux is whether developmental
services need to kick in
sooner than that
and
i think they can you know and i so
this is not
it's not perfect
at all
because it because it could
um
provide some motivation for you know not
great treatment of kids with students
older students with developmental
disabilities
um
so i guess that you know
but what that would entail would be
really rewriting 171 a to make that
really super clear so this gets us
through now it gets us through now there
is also you know this pilot we're
looking at a pilot program
um in sb 430 that um
may create some state funding and um
to
well you know go part of the way to make
sure there's funding available for
students who are in this situation okay
okay mickey you got all that
okay so we're going to add
uh
something about birthday
in line 2
or line 11
and we're going to eliminate the last
sentence
so i also have a couple other
not to continue the conversation but
things that probably should be
determined at this stage okay uh
we we anticipate at this time that there
there probably would be ample funding or
sufficient funding
in this what's already been budgeted to
cover these costs however there's
nothing in this language that would
provide any sort of direction for the
department if there was not enough money
there as far as whether this
reimbursement would be prorated
or whether you wanted to create some
sort of an access for the department to
draw a warrant to cover if the costs are
in excess of what they actually have on
hand i have no problem with drawing a
warrant okay so if we could do that that
it would be uh any any amounts that
exceed what they have available from the
special education line no we have to we
should put that money that dollar figure
in there well we that's what i'm
thinking is right now i don't i don't
anticipate needing to so we wouldn't
have an estimate i think based on
estimates we have it probably would be
covered by the catastrophic age no i'm
saying how much they're going to pony up
which was 1.4 million
for this year we have 1.4 for next year
i'm not sure it's too early to know what
the reimbursement for fiscal 23. so
it'll be 1.4 plus something to pay for
this reimbursement so we don't have a
full number yet as to what may be on
hand but i think just having a mechanism
in here for the department to draw a
warrant if necessary um would be that
way they don't have to chase a piece of
legislation next year in case they were
short make it very very if if if yes
absolutely
and the other thing is
just to be clear are we keeping the
definition that this reimbursable period
would just be services during the
2022-2023 school year because i know
there was discussion of uh summer
programs and i'm not sure if that was
wanted to be included or not no
okay okay because
by the time this legislation
finally passes gets signed
or into summer programs and there's
plenty of esra money out there for
summer programs
so
there should be absolutely no reason why
a school system can't
manage
the
one or two
i mean
but if we're talking about cat a well
special ed aid
once a school district goes over that
amount it's eligible for especially at
eight right
right
so i mean there's there's there's plenty
of money out there to cover the summer
months
so we'll we'll
drop an amendment that clarifies that it
is until their 22nd birthday
that the
sentence ending
paragraph 1 starting on line 17 will be
struck and we'll add warrant language in
the event that the department needs more
money to make the full reimbursement
payments
[Music]
and we thought this was going to be
quick
okay so this is
thank you nice handwriting whoever wrote
it
and she went bad
i've seen his writing
[Laughter]
thank you for your
work on this i know it's getting a lot
so very much nope not a not a problem
yet okay so um
i don't have this on the schedule for
tomorrow so i will
recess this until
what have i got tomorrow
376 and 401 is that tomorrow
it's tomorrow
we have one other as well force
447 or 417
yeah
that's not the right thing no yeah one
o'clock
tomorrow that's after we're here at 9.
yes we're here well the problem is the
calendar is wrong
tuesday with one o'clock uh-huh but
at nine o'clock we have a
the full committee exec session
oh right you're not saying
the executive session is at nine the
calendar is incorrect
nine o'clock
i'll have janet send out a notice but
she sent it in as nine o'clock and they
printed it at 10.
because you were supposed to have a
caucus
11 is public hearing
division two ii
right
yeah so um
so nine o'clock
janet sent out the non-germain amendment
yes
that's it's on the well it's on the
website yeah yeah
okay so mickey what do i
what do i still have
to worry about so we've got we're 20.
for tomorrow in the schedule we've got
um
senate bill 417
senate bill 401 we'll revisit we have
the discussion with dot and safety on
that bill plus that's the bill the
non-germain amendment will be
we've got senate bill 442
and senate bill 346 which we haven't
discussed either of those yet
but then we will circle back to senate
bill 376 which was the um
cit training appropriation bill
law enforcement officers
and we'll circle back on 394 i'll have
this amendment for us tomorrow
okay
so we're doing that now okay 4 20 we
still have to do this afternoon right
uh and i believe
i believe that's it
i'm missing one i feel like i'm missing
one
no that's it i think that's all of them
okay
all right 420.
i'm not sure
so mickey you have an amendment for 420
right
i do i have one that we discussed
regarding the special education section
and i do have another one a technical
amendment that the department would like
us to to consider
so i've got both of those if you want
both of those
you've got something
no he gave it to represent bucco
okay
this bill
is called extraordinary needs grant
and
this has been discussed off and on for
four years i guess
uh it was one of the um
areas that we looked at in our
last review of
education aid
which was
completed in
i think it was
and basically um
nothing happened with
that
study committee
none of the none of the recommendations
got in
so representative or senator hennessey
for those of you that don't know senator
hennessey used to be on finance
and so i am often calling her
representative hennessy which is
not right
so anyhow um
she is
introducing this bill
to
give
municipalities that are
i don't want to say poor because that's
the wrong term
their evaluation is lower is low
and
you know that can be for any number of
reasons
and this is to provide students
in those districts
with
extra
aid
okay
and um they have to
receive free and reduced lunch
price meals
okay
so
um
we'll get that free and reduced lunch
thing straightened around
again next year
it's easy to say that but that's the
best i can do
because the senate stripped it out and
uh
i'm not going to
i don't want to get in a fight over it
with
the senate again
i could but i don't care too
uh and for those that are on division
two
you remember we have hb is it 603
yes okay that we have that we have an
interim study
so
we will be having some
uh
interim study meetings on 603
and
um
one of the issues that we'll
look at in more detail
is um
the uh
green reduced lunch thing
so
i think we can't meet in july
but we can meet in august so
i'll schedule that for some time in
august
and then we have another interim study
bill which i'll schedule the same day so
that
we're not down here six times
okay
so
the first amendment
um
is a redefinition
of equalized valuation per pupil
can you tell me what
subject to taxation under rsa
82 is sure so uh mark is here from the
department and this was something that
they had identified as a
technical fix to align the bill's intent
with the data that was used for the
fiscal note and the calculation so
he could have better explain this than i
can oh okay
come on down mark
mark manganiello administrator of school
finance with the department of education
um when we when senator hennessey was
working on
senate bill 420
she kind of identified
the concept of extraordinary needs grant
and then she was
so you she knew kind of what her
objective was but then there was a lot
of data sets moving around and the data
sets on how it's based on uh
equalized valuation per fnr students so
that's the concept but then you have to
define equalize valuation and we were
running some spreadsheets and a lot of
different data sets were moving around
and
in order to get the legislation to match
the exact data set that she used in
designing this grant um the technical
amendment needs to go through
if the technical amendment doesn't go
through we still have a measurement of
equalized valuation
it would just produce a little bit
different results it would actually cost
instead of 14.7 million it would cost 15
million
and so the difference between what the
bill currently says
the bill currently defines equalized
valuation
to exclude railroads
and utilities but the way
the original intent of it was to exclude
railroads and payments in lieu of taxes
so that's a particular type of property
that's being defined there um and so in
order to match
uh
in order to have that definition match
the data set use that's the does this
definition match what dra says equalize
valuation is
uh
it matches a data set they publish
so the data is available
okay so dra wouldn't have any problem
with this definition uh i can't speak
for them but the data is available they
publish the exact column of data that we
would be using because i use that data
set okay so
is the right term equalized valuation
or do i say
a portion of the arrays equalize
valuation
methodology
what do you think mickey
mark can jump in here but i think the
idea here was to
use equalized valuation as a base but
excluding certain
components of that total overall
municipal valuation so we are using a
dra
published determined equalized valuation
less certain types of properties okay
but that doesn't say that here
it's um it's the wait it says excluding
properties
okay subject to taxation under rsa 82.
and that's that's the railroads correct
correct yeah
and the idea was to
understanding
the equalized valuations could be
inflated perhaps moving inflate is not
the right word but it was to reduce the
valuation based on certain property
types so
um
which i
yeah at all in there i don't wanna
that's all i know
okay
yeah certainly
thank you uh so can i just that i
understand they are excluded because
they would artificially inflate
property values in a community and we
want to get a more true
sense of what those valuations are to
get a better understanding of the lower
property values uh outside railroads
i can't speak really it's really um the
center would have to speak to it but
it's really just the data set she was
using there's a lot of different data
sets and
playing with the numbers she felt that
the data set
the data set that ultimately was used as
the analysis the 14.7 million dollar
analysis shows
has excludes railroads excludes pilots
and includes utilities so
the purpose of that is to get a better
actual evaluation of what the properties
are in that community but it's included
in this
it it it just makes it
i would say yes
okay
thank you to the extent that the
equalizer
number goes down if you if you're
reducing other components the possible
grants would go up just naturally the
way this formula works
yes
i guess i'm not i'm not sure whether i'm
going to let you ask any questions well
i'm not
i guess i'm not i'm not quite sure i
understand the rationale in other in
other words
for example in a community like beau
which has the power plant
if it would be my understanding that
that would contribute
a lot to sort of the wealth of the town
in the sense that to the extent
it pays
higher taxes it pays a lot of the of the
town's percentage of taxes that means
that other taxpayers in the town pay
you know relative
uh proportionally less and so why should
that
so that's yeah that's a good point uh so
just using utilities and bow as an
example so in the bill as the way it's
drafted which was not the exact attempt
uh intent of the senator it
it excludes utilities so that wealth is
not captured as part of the equation so
um
so bo
bo in that situation when you take out
the utilities it seems like a
a less wealthy property town
but now we're including it this
amendment would include those utilities
so now it
kind of like what representative murray
was talking about it would more
accurately grab more valuation data and
more accurately tell us something more
about the property values of that town
okay
uh it currently excludes 83f rsa83f
which is utilities but the amendment
would bring them back in
by not excluding them i okay i see all
right so so within and 82 is the are our
railroads yep okay and i assume that
railroads actually do bring that because
they're not basically in operation or at
least not much that brings down the
there's no yeah there's not a lot of
money all right yeah utilities are i
think are larger chunk of money sure
sure no i understand thank you thanks
for the clarification
are there any other questions on this
amendment
yeah
yeah okay
all right
so
on
uh
okay
i have a motion to accept by
representative petry do i have a second
all right gang do i have a second thank
you yes thank you
all those in favor please uh say i i i
opposed
thank you
we don't need a roll call no no we'll
we'll do the roll call as amended
okay the next amendment
is 1730
and
we want to
amend the title
and um
the reason the title needs to be amended
is because of
line five
which says amend the bill by deleting
section four
which is the um
the increase in special education
grants
and
i explained to
the education committee
that
we could do one or the other but i can't
do both
okay
if they want to bring it back into the
budget next year depending upon
how much
uh you know what our revenues are
projected to be then
we can look at it at that time but
at this point in time
we're committing ourselves to
roughly
4.
14.5 million
extra
in
in the budget so
i thought that that was about as much as
my heart could stand
so
that's what uh that's what
this bill does or this this amendment
does
on page two it's taking out from line 33
until
line seven on the next page
page
page two
line thirty three
another bill
to the end
except for the
effective date
and it leaves all the stuff in there
from the
original uh senator hennessy bill
this is uh deleting from line 33
and over on to the next page
of the first seven lines that's correct
are there any questions
on the amendment no okay
all right could i have a motion to
approve
amendment
two zero two two seventeen thirty so
approved thank you
all right
all in favor please raise your hand
okay thank you
all right now to
the bill
as we have amended it
so represent turcotte i know you have a
question
i have many madam chair oh um okay
so you're gonna have to excuse my
ignorance i'm still
that's okay mark why don't you come back
up yeah i think it'd be helpful
still learning a lot about
so
we are estimating that this
extraordinary needs grant is going to
cost somewhere
around 15 million 14 15 million or
whatever okay
let's start with a real basic question
where's that revenue coming from
it would come from the education trust
fund
and that money comes from
business taxes
uh lottery tobacco tax
a lot of sources does any of that come
from the towns themselves
the swept at 300 363 million dollars and
22 uh 300
to 263 dollars in fiscal year 23. um
that comes from uh
it's raised and retained in the town it
goes from a municipal tax collector
right to the school district but we
count we write that on our ledgers on
the education trust fund does that money
coming into the state and directly going
out to the state back to the towns
that was my understanding okay so my
question then becomes
the distribution on the the sheets here
i'm assuming that's still relatively
close to what we're looking at
okay
so could i say
that in some way
i mean i'm my understanding is there's
al already uh through the swept um a
call it a redistribution of
no mickey's
saying i see his head shaking no
okay there is no redistribution
adequacy
is that not a
so in the terms of swept
uh even if a municipality portion of a
swept exceeds their cost of a adequate
education or calculated grant they still
retain that money it does not get
turned over to the state or reallocated
but i am i understanding this that what
happens is there's going to be
um out of that fund there's going to be
a lot of towns that are not going to be
and i understand that's the whole just
to the idea but there's going to be a
lot of towns
that um
are gonna be receiving nothing
yep the fiscal note shows which towns
will receive right zero funding yeah
right
okay thank you
and and the zero funding is based on the
fact that uh
they have
they have capacity
is that the right term
to pay
whatever the difference between what the
state provides and what
so in effect donor versus non-donor town
even though that's not what's happening
but
in a roundabout way it's just that some
towns are
right are hurting more than others
sure
so my only my only question is not a
legal question well
my question i guess is this
is there anything about what we're doing
here this formula
that
in some way is sort of inconsistent with
the educational
adequacy
that we're you know that we're supposed
to provide via the the claremont
decision so that
this will
you know
hurt hurt our position in litigation in
the in the
in the claremont case in somewhere i
mean i just don't know maybe it'll help
it i'll i'll i'll tell i'll just uh
that's getting close to a legal question
so
but um no um the way so the formula
works there's constitutional adequacy
and then there's other parts of that we
call it adequacy but it's not part of
constitutional adequacy constitutional
adequacy that's being litigated at the
moment is three thousand seven hundred
and eighty six dollars and sixty six
cents per kid uh one thousand nine
hundred and something dollars for every
f r student two thousand dollars for
every sped student there's a building
blocks of the formula that's
part of constitutional adequacy and then
there's parts of the formula that are
additional funding above and beyond what
we are constitutionally required to uh
provide that includes stabilization
grants that includes relief aid which
was passed in the budget and that would
also include this grant this is above
and beyond
what the state has defined as a
constitutional adequacy
but how it impacts the courts um
most likely the courts are
i would expect them to litigate the
constitutional side of the formula not
this side of the formula but um you know
the courts are going to do what they're
going to do
representative thank you uh just so i
make sure i heard you right so
this is above and beyond any
constitutional adequacy and any other
adequacies that are out there yeah this
is the um uh this is funding
uh yes thank you
yeah uh it it it oftentimes becomes very
confusing
and
even though
some of us have been on division two for
a long time
we still learn things every single year
so
okay
are there any other questions
uh if we're are we ready for a motion oh
no
i think mickey
sorry did mickey provide a handout this
handout yes
yes
so i just wanna we've i think we've
covered a lot um and
i think the bill has amended if my
understanding is correct um
did you just suspect differential aid is
out um or i don't know if you accepted
that amendment or not um
the one thing i want to talk about is
the accountability plan that the house
added
so
this bill
as uh as uh the senate passed it just an
extraordinary needs grant the house
recently added
to receive that extraordinary needs
grant it's contingent upon
completing an accountability plan so i
just want to in the handout in the
middle section there i talk a little bit
about what that could possibly cost
for districts so in that middle section
there the accountability plan relative
to extraordinary needs grant um so the
first um looking at the data it looks
like about 80 85 school districts would
have to complete one of these plans in
order to receive an extraordinary needs
grant
and if they didn't complete one
according to the way the legislation's
written we would have to not give them
one of these grants
making the grant contingent upon
completing one of these accountability
plans could create some
administrative fiscal technical issues
it could create
people that don't want to be accountable
okay it could also do that um so the
likely the way that just so you're
understanding how the department would
implement this
we would likely include the grant
as your state revenue during the tax
setting process
and then if they did not complete it we
would dock their adequacy by that amount
to end the school year and so for a lot
of districts it wouldn't be
that much of a
dock because some of them are receiving
really small grants but for some
districts we would dock their adequacy
and then that could create
a potential budget hole if we took that
adequacy away if they did not complete
this accountability plan so i'm just
making the committee aware of that
um
lastly
these accountability plans uh uh
they
using the model of the federal
accountability laws how much these
typically cost we have a con
we have a contractor who charges 37 000
to develop one of these accountability
plans or something like this
accountability plan
so 37 to 37 200 develop a new plan
800 to revise your plan um so to do a
quality accountability plan it does cost
money this is an example of using a
contractor
and so if just to talk about the cost of
of developing that plan if we do the
37.2 k multiplied by the 85 districts
this could be 10 potentially a 3 million
dollar 3.1 million dollar cost to school
districts i don't think
that we need to have something this
complicated
okay
my goal
and
senator hennessey's goal
is to say
i am giving you manchester over three
million dollars to help your free and
reduced lunch kids what are you doing
for that a
i've hired a new teacher that will teach
reading from eight to twelve every day
and we'll teach math from
one to two or whatever the time frame is
i'm not i don't think any of us
right right you know i don't think any
of us are
looking for anything much more detailed
than that
i'm not looking for
you know a plan to build a new high
school
i'm just simply want them to tell me
what they are doing
and
and what they expect the results to be
okay if i am concentrating on the free
and reduced lunch then
to me if i measured it at the end of the
school year
in the early school year everybody's
one one and a half grades below
reading at the end of the school year
they're at
one grade below i mean it's something as
almost as simple as that so don't create
a three million dollar
program
just to solve something
that can be done
almost
right here in in this room
yes go ahead
districts must be pretty used to doing
this anyway every year they have to do
the title one application for funding
and there are goals and objectives and
and targets learning targets so this
shouldn't be i agree with um
the chair that this should be something
fairly simple my question is do you
would this plan
only
uh be attributed to those dollars that
are being used for this purpose
that's my understanding of it okay
if you if you look at the fiscal note
and um
i'll just look at the last page it says
woodstock gets 8
you know they don't need to spend 37 to
figure out how they're going to do that
represent maria
thank you so can you clarify did you put
this together you said that
that it was accountability was added
into this but were there there aren't um
proposals in that language as to how to
do this this is your proposal about how
they might do it is that i don't know
where how this fits in with the house
asking for accountability so we
currently have a federal law in essa
the average student succeeds act
that defines how accountability works
and it's for
these schools called comprehensive
support and improvement schools so a
district like manchester has some csi
schools so they're very used of going
through this exercise
uh but that's we have very few csi
schools at schools that are have um are
in the bottom five percent i believe um
in perform testing so manchester has
some ex
experience going through that process
but what the way we contract out so we
can use federal money to pay so
manchester doesn't have to pay for that
plan and do accountability by themselves
they can access
our state contract we have and the state
contract is itemized in the same the way
the table is so we're just mirroring
this off the way the federal law works
so if woodstock is getting eight
thousand dollars
you're asking them to pay 37 000 in
order to get that this is where i'm kind
of i'm losing it and that's so in order
to do a quality accountability plan it
would cost
likely more than eight thousand dollars
but
can they just send a letter to
representative umberger if if that's
sufficient for accountability the
department
would prefer that accountability is
is done with using data and bringing in
stakeholders we would we would prefer
that it be paid for by the department
with ezra funds okay yes that's what we
that's what we would prefer rather than
having every school district come in and
apply for esra funds if that's the kind
of detail that you want
i don't think it's the kind of detail
that we were looking for but
okay i don't know if we'd be able to use
esser funds for for a state program like
this but
you never know
do you try
uh
representative did you have another
question along the same lines i just
looked at that first page of the
distribution and
16 out of the 28 towns there have would
receive less money than the cost of
doing an accountability plan that's 16
out of 28. uh the other issue
so that's just a comment the other issue
is
um
i just picked a random number of 300 000
there's only 10 towns in the entire
state that are going to receive really
the lion's share of
this uh money and maybe that's the
intent but i
i can't
support that
if uh if for example um
you look at that and uh
berlin is at 377
and
they're poorer than a church mouse okay
in
in the community
and then they're talking about closing
the biomass plant so
let's throw something else ugly at them
okay
um
and franklin
oh farmington
266 and 132 yeah no the 133 is gone
yeah we we just eliminated that
that's in the fiscal note that's 24. oh
okay oh i'm sorry
yeah 20
yeah 23. yeah this is 24. 23 and then
14.7 million for 20
for 23 and then a drop in aid for 24.
and then we'll have to budget for it in
in the budget
are there any other questions
yes
so i'm still stuck on accountability
what are we asking them to do
we're just asking for
you know
obviously all of these schools get idea
money
where they have to be accountable
okay
and so
to me
this would be
you know i've got this underlying ida
money
for
school a b and c
and with this additional money this is
what i'll be able to accomplish
i don't you know i don't think we need
much more than that so it's not what's
proposed here there's nothing proposed
about this
we're not doing that no
the the front lines
that's this yeah and that's not what's
going to have to happen for these
schools to get their funding i don't
think so
there's requirements on line 17 to 29 it
goes into detail what metrics they must
analyze
so they have to do that complete that
work and demonstrate that they've
completed that work
to have a plan
on page
sorry the first uh so you got the first
title page then you go to the second
page yeah
so still on section one pages uh lines
17 through
29 and continuing and describes exactly
what the plan uh accountability process
should be
analyzing mathematics grades three
through eight um
i'm not on mine i'm
are you on 420 420 yeah first page first
page oh not the first
line 17
got it
so they can do their accountability plan
that will
be satisfactory but they don't have to
go through necessarily what you're
proposing they don't necessarily have to
hire a contractor but they do have to do
that work and so they don't have to hire
the contractor yes that's what i need to
see here but they're they're really
doing this work anyhow for idea yeah
okay
and for esr
but they have to do this work specific
to the funding they're receiving for the
state funding right
this ground
go ahead
but you need to are you you are
proposing that
school districts
work with the department of ed to
contract with these contractors to do
the work
we're using the contract as an example
to show how much it costs um only as an
example as an example of how much it
costs and that could be potentially
available to districts so in a place
like manchester where they have a grants
writer and evaluation person that person
would probably
and you said that it was only
specific to those dollars that they're
going to use coming out of this
if you have an accountability plan on
federal dollars it's it's focused on the
use of those federal dollars and how
you've improved your school with those
federal dollars so you have to mimic
that same exact process but with the
extraordinary needs grant dollars so
almost every school district in the
state does that if they're eligible for
esser funds
or for the esa money so everybody should
know how to do this
yeah i can't i just can tell you how
much it costs to have a contractor do
that process i just i just want to make
sure that we're not
imposing
another
big process on a school district
thank you
if we are i want someone to call me
i'll give you my number okay
uh representative lynn
yes um uh
represent my colleague from windham
representative sony asked me
about that i think it's a good question
if we're going to be
providing these
grants to certain districts
what about
either charter schools or the new
efas i mean do they
uh
will they fit into this somehow and if
not why not so this is based the metric
here is it's for district public schools
that would not um charter schools and
efas would not
get any of this funding
it's based on property values over fnr
students so it's it's kind of a meant to
target
communities with less property wealth
and that's because property taxes pay
for district public schools and property
taxes don't pay for charter schools so
the intent is to focus on uh
district schools who require who depend
on property wealth to fund their schools
well
i i
i mean certainly i guess
i guess i'm not clear on that i thought
i thought that charter schools were
public schools and they were funded by
at least in part by property tax they're
not they're not funded by um
they're funded by state etf dollars we
we pay we the state
okay
pay for the charter school funding
we the state pay for the ef
a the dfa's okay yeah okay all right so
i knew that was true for yesterday yeah
there is no loca there aren't no local
tax dollars that go to either of those
entities
right okay okay
just to get a little into the weeds here
if you're looking for a vehicle to fund
charter schools or efas
um you wouldn't want to use property
values you just want to find another
vehicle to fund them because this
formula wouldn't work would it make
sense for charters
thank you
represent petri
i'm ready is everybody ready
okay
make a motion too
and we all know that uh there are two
amendments
to this bill i'll i'll merge those to be
one amendment for the whole committee
yeah so we'll have a new number once i
get that i'll email it to everybody
otpa with
two amendments out of ours yeah okay and
then
okay all right so this is a
motion out to pass with amendment 1727
and 1730 on sb 420.
representative
yes
representative votes yes representative
no
representative
yes representative
thank you
um
i'll go ahead and do
the floors on this
yeah i'll do it
oh you want to do it sorry
well
might as well
okay
um
so mickey let me make sure that i
understand what we're supposed to be
doing tomorrow
i know
one o'clock
per division one o'clock correct right
and we have
senate bill 14 and uh 417
senate bill 442 and senate bill 346
which are bills we have not discussed
yet
senate bill 442 and senate bill 346.
we'll have to revisit senate bill 376
which was the law enforcement um
cit training appropriation
uh senate bill
394 which was the special education 21
year old bill we discussed this morning
and senate bill 401 which is the d.o.t
and the body cam fund appropriations
which will also take into consideration
the non-germain amendment that will have
a hearing on tomorrow morning
okay which one are the highways
401 senate bill 401 okay
okay
and we will have amendments on that if
you recall the department of
transportation had suggested a bridge
aid alternative or two so i'll get
something drafted i expect to have that
by the end of the day and i'll send that
out for everyone to have ahead of
tomorrow
i i won't it'll be up to i don't know if
the department will calculate that or
not but
okay
so
if we can finish up on
tomorrow
then we won't have to come back on
wednesday until three o'clock
um
but
if we can't
then we'll come back
on
wednesday but um representative heath
you were going to write a blurb
you'd oh you gave it to janet
okay but janet has it
okay
yeah right right she'll get those uh
later
okay
yeah that's the
that's the exact session on the seven
bills
that we've already completed
at 10 o'clock so i think i mean that's
going to go well i think because it's on
the cd so if you have three o'clock i'm
fine if it's got to be much earlier well
that's okay
well
we'll figure that out
yeah well tomorrow's nine o'clock
and i'll have janet send out a reminder
because
i read the calendar and said what are
you talking
i had a about choice words but i was i
was home
okay
so uh we'll see everyone tomorrow
morning at nine o'clock
have a good evening
take care
you